THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER,
UH, TO.
THAT IF YOU GO TO A PRIVATE, UH,
NOT PUBLIC UNIVERSITY, YOU ARE
NOT PROTECTED UNDER, UM, THE
SAME KINDS OF RIGHTS AS YOU ARE.
IF YOU GO TO A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
, UM, THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
. UH UH, WE'RE GONNA ASK THAT
THEY PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
THAT THAT THE COLLEGE THEY ARE
EX ATTENDING IS EXEMPT FROM THE
EQUITY AND HIGHER EDUCATION ACT,
WHICH IS BASICALLY THE STATE'S
VERSION OF THE TITLE IX. AND SO
FOLKS ARE ONLY THEN COVERED
UNDER TITLE IX AND WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE FEDERAL ACTION VERSUS STATE
ACTION TO BE ABLE TO GET SOME
KIND OF PROTECTION. SO WHAT?
WE'RE ASKING WHAT THIS BILL DOES
THEN IS, UH, HAVE THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO STUDENTS? JUST SO
THEY KNOW BEFORE THEY ATTEND. UM
IT ALSO ASKS. SCHOOLS AND
SCHOOLS WERE ASKED 13 YEARS AGO
TO PROVIDE LIKE A SAFE PERSON, A
DESIGNATED PERSON ON CAMPUS. UH,
FOR FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO GO TO,
UH ALL OF THE UCS HAVE DONE IT
VERY FEW AMOUNTS OF THE èC S¼ U
S¼ HAVE DONE IT, AND VERY FEW OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE DONE
IT. SO WE'RE GONNA SAY YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THAT PERSON. YOU HAVE TO
DESIGNATE IT. WE'RE GETTING YOU
A LONG CHANCE TIME. NOW WE'RE
GONNA SAY DO IT. AND NOW WE'RE
GONNA SAY THAT PERSON SHOULD
ALSO BE, UM, A CONFIDENTIAL
PERSON. UH SO PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THAT. SO BILL
THREE PART PROTECTING L GB Tð Q
PLUS WOMEN. UM WE'RE ALSO ASKING
THAT THE L Ó DO AN ASSESSMENT.
UH JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS, UH, CRAIG.
I THINK CRAIG'S HERE BOER FROM
THE EQUALITY CALIFORNIA, AND
EMILY MITCHELL, THE DEAN OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AT CONSUMERS,
RIVER COLLEGE AND CHAIR OF THE L
GB Tð Q PLUS ADVISORY COUNCIL
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
VERY GOOD. WE WELCOME MR PULSER.
YOU CAN COME FORWARD TO THE
TABLE. GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
AND LEISURE. PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CORRECT HOLD ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY, CALIFORNIA. UH, WE'RE
A PROUD COSPONSOR OF S¼ B 1491.
AND WE APPRECIATE SENATOR EKMAN,
UH, FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT TO L GB Tð Q, PLUS
STUDENTS AT STATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO THE U S¼
TRANSGENDER SURVEY, NEARLY ONE
QUARTER OF TRANS COLLEGE
STUDENTS REPORTED BEING VERBALLY
PHYSICALLY OR SEXUALLY HARASSED
WITH 16% OF THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCED HARASSMENT HAVING
LEFT COLLEGE BECAUSE THE
HARASSMENT WAS SO BAD TRANS
STUDENTS OF COLOR WERE MORE
LIKELY TO REPORT LEAVING SCHOOL
FOR THAT REASON. IN 2016 EQ èC
WAS PROUD TO SPONSOR LEGISLATION
, WHICH REQUIRED COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO DISCLOSE IF THEY
PERMIT DISCRIMINATION AGAINST L
GB Tð Q STUDENTS. SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL REQUIRED SCHOOLS TO
CLAIM AN EXEMPTION UNDER EITHER
TITLE IX OR CALIFORNIA'S EQUITY
AND HIGHER EDUCATION ACT TO
DISCLOSE THIS INFORMATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION, AS WELL AS TO BOTH
CURRENT AND PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS
AND STAFF. UNFORTUNATELY SOME
STUDENTS CONTINUE TO BE UNAWARE
OF THESE EXEMPTIONS AND WHAT THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES MIGHT BE
IF THEIR IDENTITY DOES NOT ALIGN
WITH COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY
DISCRIMINATORY POLICIES. TODAY
AT LEAST NINE INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE EXEMPT FROM TITLE
IX AND AT LEAST 20 ARE EXEMPT
FROM THE EQUITY AND HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT, AND STUDENTS
DESERVE TO KNOW WHICH SCHOOLS
HAVE A LICENSE TO DISCRIMINATE
AND IGNORE STATE AND FEDERAL
CIVIL RIGHTS PROTECTIONS. WE
APPRECIATE THE STAFF FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE ASSEMBLY
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR REPORT, WHICH INCLUDED A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
HOW THE STATE CAN BETTER PREVENT
AND ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION ON
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES,
AND THIS BILL IS ONE OF SEVERAL
FROM THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS
REPORT. IT WILL BUILD ON
EXISTING LAW BY REQUIRING THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE A WRITTEN NOTICE TO
STUDENTS WHO RECEIVE STATE STATE
FINANCIAL AID REGARDING WHETHER
THEIR INSTITUTION CLAIMS OR
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION TO STATE AND
FEDERAL NON DISCRIMINATION
PROTECTIONS AS WELL AS THE RIGHT
TO REPORT DISCRIMINATION TO THE
U S¼ DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS S¼ B 1491
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS,
ESPECIALLY TRANS STUDENTS, WHO
ARE FACING A BARRAGE OF HATE AND
VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE AWARE OF
THEIR RIGHT. IN ANY RECOURSE,
THEY MAY HAVE TO ADDRESS
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU, DEAN
MITCHELL. WELCOME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO FIRST OF ALL, IT
IS MY HONOR AND MY PRIVILEGE TO
REPRESENT THE L GB Tð Q, PLUS
STUDENT AND EMPLOYEES OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. WE ARE A SYSTEM THAT
WELCOMES 100% OF ALL SCHOLARS
AND WE EDUCATE 1.9 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. MYSELF AND THOSE
WHOM I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF TODAY
HAVE SPENT YEARS AND TIRELESS
HOURS TRYING TO IMPROVE THE
CAMPUS CLIMATE FOR L, GB Tð Q,
PLUS STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES. THE
PROVISIONS IN SB 1491 SERVED TO
IMPROVE THE CAMPUS CLIMATE IN
SEVERAL IMPORTANT WAYS. FIRST
THE INCREASED INCLUSION OF
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
AGENDA INTERSEX AND TWO SPIRIT
INTO THE DEFINITIONS OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
ALLOWS STUDENTS TO HAVE THEIR
IDENTITIES AFFIRMED IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILLS THAT SEEK
TO REPRESENT THEM. SECOND AS
SENATOR EDMON TALKED ABOUT THE
IDENTIFIED PERSON ON THE CAMPUS,
ONE OF THE SUBSTANTIAL MOVES
FORWARD IN THIS BILL IS THAT
THAT INFORMATION WOULD NEED TO
BE ON PRINTED MATERIALS AND ON
CAMPUS WEBSITES. THIS PROVIDES
THREE VERY IMPORTANT BENEFITS TO
THOSE ON CAMPUS. FIRST IT IS AN
OUTWARD AND AFFIRMATIVE SIGN TO
OUR L GB Tð Q, PLUS STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE CAMPUSES
WELCOME. PRESENCE THERE THAT
THEY ARE VALUED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY. SECOND IT PROVIDES A
LEVEL OF PROTECTION TO SAID
EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SEEK SUPPORT
DIRECTLY FROM IDENTIFIED PERSON
INSTEAD OF HAPHAZARDLY HAVING TO
ASK AROUND A CAMPUSES FOR
SUPPORT. THIS REQUIRES OFTEN
TIMES STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES TO
CONTINUOUSLY OUT THEMSELVES
ACROSS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
CAMPUS ENTITIES, POTENTIALLY
OPENING THEM UP FOR
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT.
FINALLY THE IDENTIFICATION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL IMPRINTED MATERIALS
AND ON THE WEBSITE ALSO HOLDS
THE CAMPUS'S ACCOUNTABLE AND
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE PLACED IN
THAT POSITION TO ENSURE THAT IN
FACT, THOSE CAMPUSES ARE READY
TO SERVE L GB, Tð Q STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES. AN ADDITIONAL
PROVISION WITHIN THIS BILL SB
1491 THAT IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE TO US IS, IN FACT,
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
HAVE TO SAY IT ALL IN ORDER. I
APOLOGIZE, UM, CONDUCT SORT OF
ASSESS THE CAMPUS CLIMATE EVERY
THREE YEARS. THIS IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. RESEARCH NATIONAL
RESEARCH SHOWS US THAT WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT Kò THROUGH
12 OR FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
EXPERIENCES QUEER AND TRANS
STUDENTS FEEL LESS WELCOME AND
LESS SAFE ON THEIR CAMPUSES.
VERY SIMILAR. RESEARCH IS
PRESENT FOR EMPLOYEES. DO YOU
KNOW WHAT I HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
FINISH? THANK YOU. OH, SORRY.
IT'S OK. AND SO THIS WOULD
REQUIRE, OR THIS WOULD ALLOW US
TO ASSESS THE CAMPUS AND MAKE IT
NEEDED CHANGES. WITH DEEP
GRATITUDE AND APPRECIATION. I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT S¼ B 1491.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IS SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND STATE, YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
SEEMS UNLIKELY. SIGN OF A GOOD
BILL. ARE THERE ANY ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN HERE AND WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. LET'S COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
SENATOR EDMAN OR HER WITNESSES?
NÓ I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND CONTINUING OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN CALIFORNIA,
AND I AM HAPPY TO MOVE. UH, THE
BILL WHEN IT'S TIME I APPRECIATE
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A CORNER, BUT
WE'LL MAKE NOTE. UM I FOR MY
PART, YOU KNOW, I'M I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFULNESS WITH WHICH
YOU HAVE APPROACHED THIS AND
APPRECIATE BOTH OF THE WITNESSES
BEING HERE TODAY WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE, SENATOR. LET'S LET'S CALL
THE ROLL. I SEE THE OTHER
MIDWIFE. YOU'RE NOT ON EDUCATION
. OH, HOW'S UH, I'M SORRY.
YOU'RE LIKE AN EMERITUS MEMBER.
I APOLOGIZE. UH, WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM. SO WE WILL TAKE THIS
OUT. WE'LL TAKE THE MOTION.
WE'LL TAKE THE VOTE. UH, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR EDMAN.
JUST AN ESTEEMED VISITOR. WE'RE
GLAD TO HAVE YOU BACK. YOU'RE AN
ALUM ALUMNA. LET US NOW MOVE TO
AGENDA. ITEM NUMBER ONE. SENATOR
MEJO. I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE HERE. WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY, YOU ARE PRESENTING SB
1091.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIR, UM COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
LAST YEAR. YOU HEARD S¼ B 515
FROM SENATOR UH, STERN, WHICH
ADDRESSED POLICY BARRIERS TO
CERTAIN SHADE STRUCTURES. AND
THEN IT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
THIS BILL AS B 1091 IS SEEKING
TO EXPAND THIS TO SCHOOL GROUND
GREENING PROJECTS BY CAPPING THE
REQUIRED IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
PATH OF TRAVEL TO 20. OF THE
ADJUSTER CONSTRUCTION COSTS OF
THE PROJECT IN LINE WITH FEDERAL
ADA LAW. THESE ALLERGIES ARE
REALLY STRUGG MAKING ME STRUGGLE
SPEAKING, SO I APOLOGIZE. UH,
CHILDREN, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ATTEND SCHOOLS IN URBAN AREAS
THAT ARE ILL EQUIPPED TO SHELTER
. STUDENTS FROM EXTREME HEAT ARE
AT HEIGHTENED RISK OF SUFFERING
HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES, POOR
HEALTH AND LEARNING OUTCOMES. I
ALSO HAD A BILL IN THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR LOOKING TO
HAVE SCHOOLS CREATE MASTER PLANS
TO BE READY, UH, TO HAVE A PLAN
READY TO HELP MITIGATE, UM, HEAT
, ESPECIALLY IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE, UH, THE ASPHALT GETS TO
UPWARDS OF 100 AND 45 DEGREES ON
A SUMMER DAY IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. THIS IS A DIFFERENT
APPROACH THAT IS MORE FEASIBLE
FOR OUR SCHOOLS TO TAKE AND
WE'LL ALSO HELP US GET CLOSER TO
THE GOAL OF GREENING OUR
SCHOOLS. WE KNOW THAT THE LACK
OF TREES IN NATURAL AREAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
COMMUNITIES WITH THE LOWEST
INCOMES. CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
REQUIRES SCHOOL GROUND GREENING
PROJECTS THAT REMOVE ASPHALT
PLANT TREES AND CREATE NATURE
BASED OUTDOOR LEARNING SPACES TO
BRING THE PATH OF TRAVEL TO THE
PROJECT UP TO GOOD CODE WITHOUT
A LIMIT ON THE COST. THIS AT
TIMES REPRESENTS A TREMENDOUS
BARRIER TO GRAINING SCHOOL
PROJECTS BECAUSE EVEN A SMALL
PROJECT CAN TRIGGER EXPENSIVE
UPGRADES, FOR EXAMPLE, GIVEN THE
GRANTS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
WITH CAL FRYER, CAL FIRE, UH
YOUR, UH, GIVEN A CERTAIN AMOUNT
, AND WHEN YOU HAVE TO UPGRADE
AT A HIGHER PERCENTAGE THAN 20%
THAT OVER EXCEEDS THE AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS YOU WERE GIVEN IN THE
GRANT. UM NEGATING YOUR ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY FULFILL YOUR
PROJECT. THIS MEANS THAT SCHOOLS
ARE NOT ONLY DEPRIVED OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPLEMENT
GREENING PROJECTS WHICH PROVIDE
IMPORTANT HEALTH, EDUCATION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS. THEY
ALSO MISS OUT ON MAKING SOME
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE PATH OF
TRAVEL. THE 2022. THERE HE SAID
THAT IT WOULD SUPPORT THE AXIS
NEEDS OF ALL STUDENTS WHILE
KEEPING CALIFORNIA'S POLICY IN
LINE WITH FEDERAL ACCESSIBILITY
LAWS. WE ARE TRYING TO THREAD
THE LINE HERE AND PROVIDE BOTH
BENEFITS TO UPGRADING PATH OF
TRAVEL AND ALSO ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE SOME GREENING PROJECTS THAT
MR CHAIR I'D LIKE TO NOW TURN TO
EXPERTS WHO I'M HERE TO TESTIFY.
MIKA RANDOLPH AND, UH, JUAN
ALTAMIRANO. MR REYNOLD. WELCOME
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. AND
GOOD MORNING. YOU HAVE A
GENEROUS TWO MINUTES. WONDERFUL
MY NAME IS MIA RANDOLPH. I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF REGIONAL
PROGRAMS FOR GREEN SCHOOLYARDS.
AMERICA GREEN SCHOOLYARDS.
AMERICA IS A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WORKS TO TRANSFORM ASPHALT
COVERED SCHOOL GROUNDS INTO
LIVING SCHOOL YARDS ARE FOUNDER
SHARON DANKS HAS SPENT OVER 20
YEARS ADVOCATING FOR THIS WORK
THROUGH COLLABORATION, EVIDENCE
BASED RESEARCH, POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS AND DIRECT
SUPPORT TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN
ADDITION, I'M A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF L, A S¼ LIVING SCHOOLYARD
COALITION, WHICH IS A GROUP OF
OVER A DOZEN NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS, EDUCATORS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO CREATE AND
ADVOCATE FOR EQUITABLE AND
HEALTHY SCHOOL ENVIRONMENTS IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA, AND
FINALLY, I SERVE ON LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
GREENING SCHOOLS AND CLIMATE
COMMITTEE. SB 1091 WILL REDUCE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO SCHOOL
GROUND GREENING AND MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR MANY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
, ESPECIALLY THE ONES WITH FEWER
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT GREENING
PROJECTS AND AT THE SAME TIME,
CARRY OUT INCREMENTAL UPGRADES
TO THE PATH OF TRAVEL RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE
ANY ACCESS TO TREE SHADE AT
SCHOOL, UNSHADED ASPHALT AND
RUBBER SURFACES ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS REACH HIGH TEMPERATURES
THAT ARE HAZARDOUS FOR STUDENTS
HEALTH AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THEIR EXPERIENCE AT SCHOOL.
TREES AND GREEN SPACES AND
SCHOOL GROUNDS, SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED TEMPERATURES AND BRING
MULTIPLE BENEFITS TO STUDENTS
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING
IMPROVED LEARNING OUTCOMES.
CHILDREN ARE MORE VULNERABLE
THAN ADULTS TO HIGH SURFACE
TEMPERATURES. THIS CAN IMPACT
CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY ENGAGE IN
VIGOROUS PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AND
THEIR SMALLER BODY. MASS UM TO
SURFACE AREA RATIO MAKES THEM
MORE VULNERABLE TO HEAT. WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO PIT GREENING
VERSUS PATH OF TRAVEL
IMPROVEMENTS AGAINST ONE ANOTHER
. TO THE CONTRARY, WE THINK THIS
BILL WILL BENEFIT BOTH. OFTEN
SCHOOL GROUND GREENING PROJECTS
ARE IMPLEMENTED BY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SECURE BOTH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC FUNDS
DEDICATED TO CLIMATE, RESILIENCE
, HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO
DO IS ENSURE THAT MORE OF THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS ARE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD AND THAT THESE
FUNDS ARE ABLE TO BE UTILIZED
AND EQUITABLE WAY BOTH IMPROVING
GREENING OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
PATH OF TRAVEL, WHICH OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T GET DONE. ADDING SHADE
TREES AND CREATING NATURE RICH
OUTDOOR LEARNING SPACES WILL NOT
ONLY ADDRESS ISSUES RELATED TO
EXTREME HEAT AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEMS, BUT IT
WILL ALSO BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CALIF
CALIFORNIA STARK INEQUITIES
RELATED TO ACCESS TO GREEN SPACE
, HANDS ON EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
AND HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
THEREFORE WE URGE YOUR IVO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SURE. WELCOME.
CONTRIBUTES TO OUR MENTAL HEALTH
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH, UH AND
MAKES COMMUNITIES MORE RESILIENT
TO FLOODING, SEVERE HEAT AND
EFFECTS OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS
THAT WE CONTINUOUSLY AND WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE OVER THE
NEXT DECADE OR MORE. UM AND WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW OUR
WORK CONTRIBUTES TO THE SOCIAL
COHESION OF COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE ARE
TRANSFORMING SCHOOL YARDS INTO
SAFE OUTDOOR GREEN SPACES, UH,
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO PROTECTING
KIDS FROM DANGEROUS EXTREME HEAT
AND PROMOTING PHYSICAL ACTIVITY,
MENTAL HEALTH AND OVERALL WELL
BEING THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
GREEN SCHOOL YARDS. MORE
CAMPUSES WILL BE, UH, WILL BE
GREENED OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS. UM THIS IS THIS IN LARGE
Dð PART TO THE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS THAT THAT YOU ALL
ALLOCATED FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
WHAT WE NEED MORE FUNDING FOR
MORE, UH, TO GREEN, MORE
CAMPUSES IN EVERY DISTRICT. WE
KNOW, HOWEVER, THAT FROM OUR
EXPERIENCING EXPERIENCE AND
REIMAGINING THESE HOT PARKING
LIKE ASPHALT PLAYGROUNDS IS THAT
THERE ARE CHALLENGE CHALLENGES.
UH WHICH THIS BILL AIMS TO
ADDRESS BY CAPPING THE REQUIRE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PATH OF
TRAVEL. TO 20% OF THE ADJUSTED,
UH, CONSTRUCTION COSTS OF THE
PROJECT IN LINE WITH FEDERAL A
Dð A LAW WE WILL BE ABLE TO BE
BETTER TO BUDGET BB A. WE WILL
BE ABLE TO BETTER BUDGET
PROJECTS AND GET MORE GREENING
ON CAMPUSES. WE FACE CHALLENGES,
BOTH IN FUNDING GREEN
PLAYGROUNDS THEMSELVES. UH AND
ALSO, UH, FUNDING A Dð. A ACCESS
INSIDE THE BUILDINGS OFTEN
GRANTS THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
COBBLE TOGETHER TO BUILD. UH,
THESE TYPE OF PROJECTS DON'T
ALLOW FOR INSIDE BUILDING
MATERIALS TO BE COVERED, AND,
UH, FROM FROM PRIVATE DOLLARS
THAT WE FUNDRAISE TO PAY FOR
THESE TYPE OF, UH, TYPE OF
PROJECTS. UH, OFTEN TIMES
PRIVATE DOLLARS. DON'T WANT TO
PAY FOR THESE TYPE OF UPGRADES.
UM SO WE KNOW THAT MANY OF THESE
CAMPUSES WE BUILT A LONG TIME
AGO, AND WE KNOW FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE IN BUILDING THESE,
UH, THESE PROJECTS IS THAT OFTEN
TIMES WHEN WE START REMOVING
MATERIAL BUILDING MATERIAL FROM
INSIDE. WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
WE'RE GONNA FIND OFTENTIMES.
LEADING TO THE COST OF THE
PROJECT, UH, BALLOONING MORE
THAN THE ACTUAL GREENING PROJECT
ITSELF. AND SO IT'S FOR THOSE
REASONS THAT WE BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
CONCENTRATING ON THE PATH OF
TRAVEL REALLY OUTSIDE, UH, IN
THE GREEN SPACE, UH, THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO OFTEN, I'LL SAY FOR
MYSELF AND MY ORGANIZATION.
WE'RE WE'RE A MORE WELL
RESOURCED ORGANIZATIONS THAN
MOST NONPROFITS. OFTEN TIMES
THESE THESE SCHOOLYARD PRO, UH,
PROJECTS ARE YOU KNOW? THE
NONPROFITS ARE HELPING CREATE
THE SPACE. THEY THEY'RE
OPERATING BUDGET IS PROBABLY NÓ
MORE THAN $2 MILLION, RIGHT? AND
SO THESE GRANTS REALLY HELP THEM
BUILD THESE PROJECTS ON THE
GROUND. UH, GET HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE FOR A LOT OF KIDS, UH
AND THE LAST THING I'LL SAY WE
APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAD, AND, UH AS UM,
THE MY CO AUTHOR. UH, COSPONSOR,
UH, SAID, WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
PIT UH, GREEN SCHOOL YARDS
AGAINST A Dð. A UH WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE IN INCLUSIVE ACCESS FOR
ALL AND OUR PLAYGROUND DESIGN.
UH AND HOW WE BUILD OUR OUR OUR
PROJECTS ARE ENGAGED OUR
ENGAGEMENT THROUGH STUDENTS,
PARENTS, TEACHERS AND STAFF ALL
OVERALL AND IT'S A REFLECTION OF
THE SCHOOL. UH, AND WHAT? THEY
NEED WHAT THEY NEED. UH AND WE
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING, UH,
TO HAVE THAT, UH, ALL INCLUSIVE
DESIGN, UH, AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF ALL THESE PROJECTS. SO UH,
WITH THAT, I, UH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND ASK FOR
AN I VOTE ON THIS BILL. I THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
HERE IN THE WITNESS ROOM WOULD
LIKE TEST ON BEHALF OF THE
MEASURE. WELCOME YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS. SAM NATIONAL
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF SUPPORT. UH,
CHRISTINA HILDEBRAND ON BEHALF
OF A VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY
AND NON TOXIC SCHOOLS, AND WE
THANK SENATOR MENDAR FOR
CONTINUING THIS THIS YEAR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IS
ANYBODY HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY? IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
WELCOME. PLEASE COME TAKE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE. AND YOU HAVE EQUAL
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS,
CALIFORNIA WERE ACTUALLY A
TWEENER ON THIS ONE. IT'LL HAVE
FORMAL OPPOSITION ON IT. WE
THINK THE AUTHOR OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COSPONSOR FOR
CONTINUED DIALOGUE AROUND THIS,
UM IF YOU AND IN GREEN SPACES AS
A KEY PART OF SCHOOLS AND ALSO
PATH OF TRAVEL AS A KEY PART OF
SCHOOLS AS WELL. SO UM, LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DIALOGUE, UH, TO, UH, REACH A
RESOLUTION. I JUST WANT TO
ARTICULATE A FEW OF OUR CONCERNS
. UM UNDER CURRENT STATE LAW,
WHEN ALTERATIONS OR ADDITIONS
ARE MADE TO EXISTING BUILDINGS
OR FACILITIES AND ACCESSIBLE
PATH OF TRAVEL TO THE SPECIFIC
AREA OF ALTERATION, OR ADDITION
MUST BE PROVIDED. THIS BILL
LIMITS THE COST OF COMPLYING
WITH THE REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE
AN ACCESSIBLE PATH OF TRAVEL TO
A SCHOOL GROUND GREENING PROJECT
ON A SCHOOL CAMPUS TO 20% OF THE
ADJUSTED CONSTRUCTION COSTS OF
THE PROJECT. OUR CORE CONCERN IS
THAT THE BILL WOULD SUBVERT THE
WAY THAT THE LAW PROVIDES FOR
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT TO BECOME
ACCESSIBLE OVER TIME. THE ADA
AND EXISTING STATE LAW SPECIFIED
THAT SCHOOL FACILITIES BUILT
BEFORE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE LAWS DO NOT NEED TO MAKE
THESE ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS
RIGHT AWAY. HOWEVER NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE BUILT ACCESSIBLE
FROM THE ONSET OF THE PROJECT.
AND TO THE EXTENT PRE EXISTING
FACILITIES ARE RENOVATED
ACCESSIBILITY, INCLUDING AN
ACCESSIBLE PATH OF TRAVEL MUST
BE PROVIDED. THE INTENT BEHIND
EXISTING LAW WAS TO ENSURE THAT
ACCESSIBILITY WAS TO BE PROVIDED
OVER TIME. AND THIS BILL,
UNFORTUNATELY, DELAYS OR
JEOPARDIZES THE PROVISIONS
REGARDING ACCESSIBILITY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
EXISTED FOR YEARS. THIS BILL
WOULD WALK BACK STATE
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT HOW MUCH
ACCESSIBILITY WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE. WAY THAT THE BILL IS
STRUCTURED CURRENTLY REDUCES THE
AMOUNT IN WHICH ACCESSIBILITY
UPGRADES NEED TO BE FUNDED. AND
THERE IS NÓ TIME LIMIT REGARDING
THOSE REDUCTIONS, MEANING THAT
GREENING RENOVATIONS COULD BE
MADE FOR DECADES INTO THE FUTURE
WITHOUT TRIGGERING THE
REQUIREMENT OF FULL
ACCESSIBILITY. AT SOME POINT IN
ORDER TO FULFILL THE PROMISE OF
THE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
ACT AND RELATED STATE LAWS TO
CHILDREN WITH PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES. SCHOOLS DO NEED TO
BECOME FULLY PHYSICALLY
ACCESSIBLE. THIS BILL WOULD RISK
DELAYING THAT PROCESS SINCE IT
ALLOWS FOR SCHOOL GROUND
RENOVATION WITHOUT FULL
ACCESSIBILITY. IF THE PATH OF
TRAVEL WERE, UH TO A PLAY AREA
WERE NOT MADE ACCESSIBLE AS A
RESULT OF THE TYPE OF RENOVATION
AT WHAT POINT HAS IT BECOME
FULLY ACCESSIBLE. NOW WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHOR'S
CONCERN THAT WITHOUT THIS BILL,
IMPORTANT SCHOOL TRAINING
MEASURES WOULD NOT TAKE PLACE AT
ALL. CURRENT LAW ALREADY
PROVIDES EXCEPTIONS TO GUARD
AGAINST THE COSTS OF BARRIER
REMOVAL, UH, UNREASONABLY,
OVERSHADOWING THE COST OF A
RENOVATION. THE COST OF
COMPLYING WITH THE REQUIREMENT
TO PROVIDE AN ACCESSIBLE PATH OF
TRAVEL IS ALREADY LIMITED TO 20%
OF THE ADJUSTED CONSTRUCTION
COSTS FOR THE PROJECT. FOR
PROJECTS THAT DO NOT EXCEED THE
CURRENT VALUATION THRESHOLD. AND
EVEN IN CASES WHERE THE COST OF
THE PROJECT DOES EXCEED THE
VALUATION THRESHOLD. THE CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS FOR Dð S¼ A TO GRANT
AN EXEMPTION TO THE REQUIREMENT
OF A FULLY COMPLIANT PATH OF
TRAVEL IF THE COST OF DOING SO
WOULD BE AN UNREASONABLE
HARDSHIP. THE CURRENT VERSION OF
THE BILL, BY CONTRAST, WOULD
ALLOW A LIMIT OF 20, REGARDLESS
OF THE SIZE OF THE RENOVATION
PROJECT. REGARDLESS OF THE
EXTENT OF WHICH, PROVIDING AN
ACCESSIBLE PATH OF TRAVEL WOULD
ACTUALLY BE A FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
AND REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
GREENING PROJECT WAS FUNDED BY A
NONPROFIT OR BY THE SCHOOL
ITSELF. IT ALSO APPLIES THE 20%
LIMITATION TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
, WHICH TYPICALLY HAVE FAR
GREATER RESOURCES THAN DISTRICTS
SERVING PRIMARY OR SECONDARY
SCHOOLS. MR KRAMER INVESTED TO
FINISH UP. ABSOLUTELY WE
APPRECIATE THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL TO PROVIDE GREATER
DEFINITION TO THE GREENING
PROJECTS BUT STILL HAVE THESE
CONCERNS AND, UH, WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
COMMITTEE AND CO SPONSORS. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY, SIR. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE? UH, HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WANTS TO
TESTIFY? IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SEEING NONE. UH LE, LET'S
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS FOR SENATOR MEN? I
JUST LIKE TO GIVE THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO THE
CONCERNS THAT THE, UM THAT THE
OPPOSITION EXPRESSED IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YEAH, AND I'M
HAPPY THAT, UM THEY'RE A TWEENER
RIGHT NOW. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY ON THIS BILL. WE'VE
ENGAGED, ENGAGED ALL
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE GET GO,
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS AND SO MANY
OTHER ISSUES. YOU KNOW, I'M
LOOKING AT THIS BILL. UM, AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE. A GOOD
COMPROMISE. WE'RE NOT LOWERING
THE THRESHOLD OF THE OF THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. AND IN
FACT, WHEN I TALKED ABOUT THE
CAL FIRE GROUNDS, THEY
THEMSELVES OUR OWN STATE GRANTS
ONLY, UH UH, PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
20% OF, UM A Dð IMPROVEMENTS, SO
WE'RE MATCHING A LOT OF OUR
ALREADY STATE GRANTS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATED FOR GREENING OUR
SCHOOLS. IDEALLY IN A PERFECT
WORLD. IF WE WERE THREE YEARS
AGO, WHEN WE WERE IN THE
SURPLUS, WE WOULD ALLOCATE
ENOUGH FUNDING TO DO THE
NECESSARY UH OR TO INCREASE. UH
THE, UH, IMPROVEMENTS FOR A Dð
ON THE PATH TO TRAVEL ABOVE 20%
BUT WE'RE NOT. WE'RE RIGHT NOW,
UM, IF WE PASS 1091, WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS. IF WE DON'T WE WON'T
HAVE ANY MONEY FOR IMPROVEMENTS
OF PATH TO TRAVEL. AND WE WON'T
HAVE ANY MONEY FOR GREENING OUR
PROJECTS. UM SO THIS IS I'M SEEN
AS A WAY TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
TWO INJUSTICES THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AGAIN. SENATOR I WISH WE
CAN COME UP WITH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO SOLVE ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO SOLVE. BUT IF WE
CAN FIND A SOLUTION THAT GETS
INCHES US TOWARDS IN THE
POSITIVE MANNER ON TWO DIFFERENT
ISSUES, I DO CONSIDER THAT A
WIN. I, AND I APPRECIATE THAT
FOR MY PART. UH, I APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWER. UH, I WANT TO ADD A
FEW NOTES. SO II. I WANT TO
THANK YOU NOT JUST FOR THIS
BILL, BUT FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS TO
GRANTING SCHOOL YARDS. I KNOW
THAT'S FROM YOUR OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE, BUT ALSO A DEEP
APPRECIATION OF THE NEEDS AND
NOT JUST YOUR CONSTITUENTS. BUT
ANY ANY KID GOING TO A SCHOOL
THAT THAT LACKS A GREEN SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT. AND THERE ARE FAR
TOO MANY OF THEM. UH, CLEARLY,
THE GOAL HERE IS TO FIND A
CREATIVE WAY TO INCENTIVIZE Kò
THROUGH 14 LOCAL AGENCIES TO
UNDERTAKE SCHOOL GRANTING
PROJECTS. UH AND I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE NOT INTENDING TO
CREATE A TENSION BETWEEN
DISABILITY ADVOCATES, UH, AND
THIS GOAL, BUT I, I DO THINK MR
KRAMER RAISES SOME VALID
CONCERNS. UH, ACCESSIBLE PATH OR
TRAVEL REQUIREMENTS SERVE TO
GUARANTEE EQUAL ACCESS TO THE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. UM,
AND THAT IS A DEMOGRAPHIC THAT
HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDERSERVED, AND UNFORTUNATELY,
IT'S QUITE EXPENSIVE TO MAKE
THOSE COMMOS, UH, WHEN WE CAP
THE AMOUNT OF A Dð A COMPLIANCE
WORK WOULD OTHERWISE BE REQUIRED
TO DO TO HIS POINT. WE RISK OF
FURTHER DELAYING THE DATE BY
WHICH ALL FACILITIES ARE
EVENTUALLY FULLY ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL STUDENTS, AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT PROJECTS
EXCEEDING THE VALUATION
THRESHOLD CAN ALREADY SUBMIT AN
UNREASONABLE HARDSHIP WAIVER TO
THE STATE ARCHITECT, UH, WHERE A
CASE BY CASE ANALYSIS, LOOKING
AT MULTIPLE FACTORS WOULD BE
DONE. SO YOU KNOW, TO YOUR POINT
. THIS IS ABOUT TRADE OFFS AND
STRIKING A BALANCE. II. I WOULD
ASK YOU, SENATOR MEAR. I KNOW
THIS IS NOT A HARD QUESTION.
ANSWER THAT FOR YOU TO COMMIT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
DISABILITY. COMMUNITY TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE FIND COMMON GROUND,
ESPECIALLY AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD 1000% MR CHAIR AND I'VE
YOU KNOW, I'VE COMMITTED MYSELF
SINCE MY IN MY SHORT TENURE HERE
IN, UM ADVANCING EVERYTHING
RELATED TO, UM THE POPULATION OF
I Dð Dð AND THAT IS A REALLY
CLOSE AND PERSONAL PASSION OF
MINE. SO I WANNA MAKE SURE WHILE
WE'RE ADDRESSING OTHER
INJUSTICES, WE'RE NOT CREATING
OTHERS. AND I DO COMMIT TO THAT.
ALL RIGHT, I. I DO APPRECIATE
THAT COMMITMENT. UH, WITH THAT,
LET'S CALL THE ROLE WE DO HAVE
IMPRESSION. NEWMAN NEWMAN, HERE,
OCHO OCHO HERE, CORTES! CORTESE
HERE, GLAZER GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. PRESENT PRESENT, SENATOR
, IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE AND THANK YOU,
SENATOR FOR ALLOWING ME TO, UM,
UM BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS VALID CONCERNS 100%
IN IDEAL WORLD. WOULD BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM, AND EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL
WOULD HAVE 100% IMPROVEMENTS TO
BE ADA FOR ALL KIDS TO BE ABLE
TO PLAY FREELY AND HOWEVER WAY
OR FORM THAT IS TO THEM. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE ALSO THAT OUR KIDS
HAVE SHADE STRUCTURES THAT HAVE
GREENING. UM UH, UH, PROJECTS IN
THEIR SCHOOLS THAT IT'S NOT JUST
AS FAR METAL STRUCTURES. I KNOW
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION, BUT WE STILL
NEED TO MAKE SURE UH, THAT WE'RE
CREATING POLICIES ARE EQUITABLE
ACROSS OUR ENTIRE ENTIRE STATES
THAT MEET OUR DESERT AREAS OR
OUR VALLEYS. AND SO FORTH. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ENGAGING
WITH ME ON THAT AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I THANK YOU. AND WITH
THAT, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE WRONG BUT WE DON'T HAVE
A MOTION TO MOVE. WILL SENATOR
WILK MOVES THE BILL? UH AND
PLEASE CALL THE ROOM. ITEM ONE
S¼ B 1091 MENDAR. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN, I OCHO
BOG. I OCH I CORTESI CORTESE I
GLAZER GONZALEZ, SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS, WILK WILK. AYE. THAT
MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS FOUR
VOTES. WE'LL KEEP IT OPEN, BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND SO
NEXT. I SHOW ITEM NUMBER THREE.
I MY UNDERSTANDING IS, SENATOR
HURTADO HAS SAID OH, HAS HAD
SOME CHALLENGES WITH TRAVEL. BUT
WE DO HAVE A SENATOR HERE,
SENATOR WAHAB. UH, IT IS GOOD TO
SEE YOU, MR CHAIR WHILE SHE'S
COMING UP. CAN WE VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR? YOU CERTAINLY
CAN. IF YOU DON'T IF YOU DON'T
MIND, SENATOR. WHAT UP? UH, LET
US NOW TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT? SO MOVED. MOVED
BY SENATOR WILK, MAN OF
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE TWO ITEMS ON CONCERNED.
HOLD IT. HOLD IT, SENATOR.
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO PULL OFF.
YOU KNOW ANY OF YOUR BILLS. I
WANT TO PULL OFF RIGHT? ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NEWMAN NEWMAN,
I OCHO OCHO, I CORTESE CORTESE.
I GLAZER GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WILKY WILK. AYE ALL. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENTLY HAS
FOUR VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR WILL
HAVE YOU YOU'RE PRESENTING SB
1318 AT YOUR, UH, LEISURE.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. CHAIR
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. UM FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK CORDELL FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS BILL AND I ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS. SPECIFICALLY I WANNA
TALK ABOUT SB 1318, WHICH
ENSURES THAT STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS ON SCHOOL CAMPUS RECEIVE
CARE FOR A QUALIFIED BEHAVIOR
FROM A QUALIFIED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL IN JUST
SEVEN YEARS. THE SUICIDE RATE
AMONG CHILDREN AGED 10 TO 14
MORE THAN DOUBLED. AND THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE PANDEMIC,
INTENTIONAL SELF HARM AMONG
CHILDREN, 13 TO 18 INCREASED BY
91. WE ARE EXPERIENCING AN
UNPRECEDENTED SURGE IN CHILD
SELF HARM, AND IT IS TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE ACTION. SB
1318 REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO REVISE THEIR MODEL
YOUTH SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICY
TO INCLUDE CRISIS INTERVENTION
PROCEDURES THAT PRIORITIZE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
AND TWO CLARIFY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT, INCLUDING RESOURCE
OFFICERS SHOULD ONLY BE INVOLVED
WHEN THERE IS AN IMMINENT THREAT
TO THE STUDENT'S LIFE. SB 1000
THREE. 118 IS A STEP TOWARDS THE
PROTECTION OF OUR CHILDREN
CONNECTING THEM TO THE RESOURCES
AND PROFESSIONALS THEY NEED. I
SPECIFICALLY WANNA ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THAT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES,
FIRST GENERATION AND FOSTER CARE
, UM MANY OF WHICH I REPRESENT
PERSONALLY, OFTENTIMES FAMILIES
ARE NOT NECESSARILY WELL
EQUIPPED TO TALK TO THEIR
CHILDREN ABOUT ISSUES THAT THEIR
CHILDREN ARE STRUGGLING WITH. UM
EITHER. IT'S BECAUSE OF A LACK
OF TIME OR, UM, A LITTLE BIT OF
AN UNDERSTANDING ISSUE OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE. THE
CHILD MAY NOT FEEL SAFE EITHER.
AND THIS IS SCHOOLS SPECIFICALLY
EVEN AS A FOSTER KID JUMPING
FROM SCHOOL TO SCHOOL TO SCHOOL
SCHOOLS ARE ONE OF THE MOST
CONSTANT. THINGS IN THEIR LIFE.
THEY GO THERE EVERY DAY. THEY
BUILD A RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
COLLEAGUES, THEIR CLASSMATES,
THEIR TEACHERS AND SO FORTH. AND
IT IS OFTEN SUPPOSED TO BE A
SAFE PLACE IF THEIR HOME IS NOT
A SAFE PLACE. SO WITH ME, I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE NATHAN AND I'M
SORRY. NATHAN NÓ, A FORMER
STUDENT IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY,
AS WELL AS TONY GUERO, UM, WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR NÓ. WELCOME. UH PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS KHÓ AND I ATTENDED
FREMONT HIGH SCHOOL IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. I WANT TO EXTEND
MY APPRECIATION TO SENATOR WAHAB
FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS
COURAGEOUS BILL THAT PRIORITIZES
PROTECTING STUDENTS WHEN THEY
NEED IT. MOST. BEFORE I BEGIN. I
WANT TO APPLAUD THE LEGISLATURE
FOR ITS CURRENT EFFORTS TO
REFORM OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
POLICIES LIKE ONES THAT EXPAND
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
AND MAKE MENTAL HEALTH. PART OF
A CHILD'S CURRICULUM
DEMONSTRATES THEIR COMMITMENT TO
CENTER PREVENTION AND PROMOTE
WELL BEING. NOT MERELY TO TREAT
SYMPTOMS AS THEY ARISE. BUT THE
REASON I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT OUR
STRIDES TOWARDS THAT OUR STRIKES
TOWARDS INTERVENTION DON'T
MIRROR OUR STRIDES TO, UM
TOWARDS PREVENTION. I STAND
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO REMIND
EVERYONE THAT WE NEED TO RETHINK
CRISIS INTERVENTION, WHICH
REMAINS ONE OF THE GREATEST
UNADDRESSED FLAWS IN OUR SYSTEM
TODAY. I WAS A SOPHOMORE IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHEN I EXPERIENCED A
SUICIDAL EPISODE ON CAMPUS. THIS
EPISODE WAS TRIGGERED WHEN MY
SCHOOL ADVOCATE WAS FORCED TO
NOTIFY POLICE OFFICERS, UM, TO
LOOK INTO IF I WAS BEING ABUSED
THOSE SAME POLICE OFFICERS
MONTHS BEFORE NOTIFIED MY
PARENTS THAT MY SISTER AND I
MADE AN ANONYMOUS REPORT, UM,
THAT WE WERE BEING ABUSED AT
HOME. THIS ISN'T A STORY WHERE
THE SURVIVOR FINDS THE COURAGE
TO SPEAK UP AND THEY WIN THE DAY
INSTEAD, I WAS HANDCUFFED IN
FRONT OF THE SCHOOL. AND IN
FRONT OF MY PEERS AS WELL. I WAS
GETTING LOADED INTO A SQUAD CAR.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A
CHILD IS SUICIDAL. I WAS LUCKY
BECAUSE I HAD SOMEONE LIKE MY
SCHOOL ADVOCATE. I'M HERE FOR
THE MILLIONS OF STUDENTS WHO
HAVE AN INFINITELY HIGHER
MOUNTAIN TO CLIMB THAN I DID,
WHO ATTEND SCHOOLS THAT DON'T
HAVE ANY SOCIAL, CLINICAL OR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND WHO
ONLY HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT ON
THEIR CAMPUS. S¼ B 1318 WOULD HÌ
EXISTING STATE POLICY THAT
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO CALL 911.
WHEN A STUDENT IS EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS, IT WILL
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS LIKE ME
REFERRED TO MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS RATHER THAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IT WILL ENSURE THAT
FOR STUDENTS IN THEIR DARKEST
MOMENTS, THERE'S A LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL AND NOT THE
INSIDE OF A SQUAD CAR. FOR THAT
REASON, I URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
M TRE WELCOME. I WANNA SAY IT
WAS VERY MOVING. EXCUSE ME. MR
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBER, SENATOR
W STAFF. WE'RE TONY TRU ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION, AND WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK
DONE BY THE SENATOR STAFF AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF TO GET US
HERE TODAY. WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DETAILED
ANALYSIS WITH THE EFFORT IN
CALIFORNIA TO EXPAND MEDICAL
COVERAGE TO ALL MEDICAL ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS TO HAVE BEGUN IN 2015
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SUBMITTED A STATE
PLAN AMENDMENT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT èC Tð, A AND MANY OF
THE COSPONSOR OF S¼ B. 1318 IT
WORKED TIRE TIRELESSLY TO
MAXIMIZE THE PRESENCE OF PUPIL
SERVICES PERSONNEL AT SCHOOL
SITES. PARTICIPATING IN THE
FEDERAL BILLING OPTION PROGRAM
RECEIVED FINANCIAL
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR BOTH SERVICES
AND STAFF, DELIVERING AUTHORIZED
PHYSICAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS TO MEDICAL ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS. WHILE EE A S¼ AWAIT
THE WORK PRODUCT REQUIRED IN A B
309. IT'S REFERENCED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS. MAKING SURE THAT L A
ARE ADDRESSING STRATEGIC
STAFFING AND FUNDING DECISIONS
BENEFITING STUDENTS IN THE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY IS IN
EVERYONE'S BEST INTEREST.
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH
INDIVIDUALIZED AND ONGOING
COUNSELING SERVICES ON THEIR
SCHOOL CAMPUS MINIMIZES LOST
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME AND MAXIMIZES
THE BENEFITS OF A MODEL IN WHICH
PROFESSIONALS CAN EVALUATE AND
ADDRESS THE NATURAL EXTERNAL
FACTORS THAT PLAY A CENTRAL ROLE
IN CHILDHOOD BEHAVIOR DISORDERS.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION,
STUDENTS ARE 10 TO 21 TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO RECEIVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES WHEN THEY ARE
PROVIDED ON A SCHOOL CAMPUS, AND
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF RESEARCH
DOCUMENTING THE IMPORTANCE OF
EMBEDDED SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE
MORE ACCURATE DIAGNOSES AND
BETTER IDENTIFICATION OF CAUSAL
FACTORS. EMBEDDED SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
PROVIDE MORE ACCURATE DIAGNOSES
AND BETTER OF AGGRAVATING
FACTORS. SCHOOL BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS HAVE UNIQUE
ADVANTAGE OF OBSERVING CHILDREN
IN NATURAL PLAY AND IN ACADEMIC
SETTINGS. IN A POLL CONDUCTED IN
THE FALL OF 2022 OF CURRENT AND
FORMER èC Tð, A MEMBERS THAT
THERE WERE A VARIETY OF CHANGES
THEY BELIEVE WOULD ADDRESS THE
BURNOUT AND IMPROVE TEACHER
RETENTION, INCLUDING REDUCING
THE STRESS CURRENT EDUCATORS ARE
FEELING IN THEIR JOBS BY BETTER
STAFFING AND MORE SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS. STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES REFERRED TO OFF
CAMPUS CLINICS ARE MUCH LESS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE INITIAL OR
ONGOING SERVICES THAN MOST
OFFERED THAN THOSE OFFERED
SERVICES AT A SCHOOL SITE,
SCHOOL BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
SCHOOL DISCIPLINARY ACTION
REFERRALS INTO THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND SCHOOL
DROPOUT RATES. MR GAR HAVE TO
ASK YOU TO FINISH UP. WE SO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN I VOTE.
I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. DO
YOU HAVE ANOTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM LIKE TO TEST
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE BILL? IF
SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD. STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION, PLEASE. JOHN Dð
AT THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT. AMANDA DICKIE, ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT. WE'RE REALLY
PROUD TO BE A COSPONSOR AND VERY
PROUD OF NATHAN. THANK YOU.
SABRINA MEANS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS, A COSPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ASSOCIATION. I'M SORRY
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION BOTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS IN SUPPORT. THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE. SEEING NONE. LET'S COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. I KNOW
TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE ARE
CO-AUTHOR ON THIS BILL ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? FOR THE
AUTHOR. SENATOR CHO BOOK, I DO,
UM SO I'M KIND OF CURIOUS AS TO
THE PORTION AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE THE AUTHOR AN OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON THE
ROLE OF PARENTS WITHIN THIS BILL
. UM BECAUSE I AGREE ON ON THE
NOTION THAT, UM, LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS NOT NECESSARILY THE FIRST.
POINT OF CONTACT THAT SHOULD BE
MADE. UM UNLESS, OF COURSE, AND
THERE WAS A SITUATION IN OUR
SCHOOL WHERE WE HAD A CHILD. UM
ONE OF OUR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS
WHERE WE, UM, HAD A CHILD WHO
WAS LITERALLY AT THE, UM UM, ON
THE SECOND FLOOR. AT THE BORDER,
AND, UM OF COURSE, TEACHERS
COUNSELORS. EVERYBODY WAS WAS
ALERTED. BUT QUITE FRANKLY, I
THINK ALL OF THEM WOULD HAVE
BEEN. REALLY REALLY. I'M
ASSUMING I DIDN'T TALK TO THEM
PERSONALLY, BUT I'M ASSUMING
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE TRYING TO HELP
THAT CHILD. IF SOMETHING WERE TO
HAPPEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT MAY
HAVE BEEN CALLED. I DON'T KNOW
THE DETAILS, BUT I WOULD. I'M
JUST THINKING OF THE SCENARIOS
IN THAT CASE. WHERE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT COULD BE VERY
TRAUMATIC FOR EVERYONE AND THE
NEED OR THE JUDGMENT CALL OF
CALLING LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THAT IN THAT
INSTANT. BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE ROLE OF PARENTS CAUSE I
THOUGHT YOU'RE YOUR COMMENT AT
THE BEGINNING WITH REGARDS TO
OUR FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT,
UH, PARENTS, UM, COMING INTO
THIS COUNTRY AND, UM HAVING OR
NOT? MAYBE THE, UM INFORMATION
OR THE EDUCATION THE PREPARATION
TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. UH, VARIES, OF COURSE
AND A SCHOOL, OF COURSE. UM BUT
ALSO THE LANGUAGE BARRIERS, BUT
THAT WOULD NOT JUST BE INHERENT
TO PEOPLE WHO 100% MIGRANTS OR
IMMIGRANTS, BUT ALSO TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN HERE THROUGH THEIR
WHOLE LIVES AND DON'T HAVE A
CULTURE IN THEIR HOME OF TALKING
ABOUT BEHAVIORAL. I MEAN, IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. UM LOSE ITS STIGMA BY
HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND
DIALOGUE AND PRESENTATIONS ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. SO WITH THAT
IN MIND, I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
YOUR THANK YOU. UM SO YOU KNOW,
I. I SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED THAT
JUST BECAUSE I'VE SEEN A LOT OF
THE STRUGGLES, AND THERE'S A
COUPLE OF OTHER BILLS. I'M
CARRYING THAT ADDRESS A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT AS WELL. RIGHT UH,
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND EVEN
PROP 63 THAT ALLOWED FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
KIND OF STEP INTO THE
COMMUNITIES, HIRE THE PEOPLE
THAT SPEAK THE SAME LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE AND SO FORTH AND BE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT WHEN
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH AND SO FORTH, SO I FULLY
SUPPORT THAT, AND WE OBVIOUSLY
NEED TO EXPAND THAT AND MUCH
MORE. I WILL STAY WITH THIS
PARTICULAR THING. UM THIS
PARTICULAR BILL, I WANNA SAY
THAT SCHOOL STAFF AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO WEIGH IN WHETHER
NOTIFICATION TO THE PARENT WILL
CAUSE HARM TO THE CHILD, THE
FIRST AND BIGGEST PRIORITY. UM
IN DEALING WITH THIS IS MAKING
SURE THE CHILD IS SAFE. THAT'S
NUMBER ONE. I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE UPON THAT. THE ONLY THING
THAT 1318 CHANGES IS THAT THE
EXISTING PARENT NOTIFICATION
CONSIDERATIONS SHOULD BE NOTED
IN THE MODEL POLICY AND THAT
SCHOOL OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SHOULD CONSULT WITH A
CHILD WHEN THEY'RE MAKING THAT
DECISION, AND THAT'S JUST ASKING
THE KID UM SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
CURRENT LAW, THE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST MAKES THE
DETERMINATION WHETHER OR NOT TO
NOTIFY THE PARENT OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS, BASED ON WHETHER
THERE IS ANY RECORD OF PARENTAL
ABUSE IN THE STUDENT'S RECORD.
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW, RECORDS ARE
ACTUALLY NOT, UM, UH, THERE THAT
SHOW ABUSE AND MAYBE THAT YOU
KNOW, THE KID HAS BEEN KEEPING
IT A SECRET FOR SO LONG BEFORE
IT BECOMES A PARENT, OR, UH,
THEY HAVE A CRISIS IF 1318 WERE
ADOPTED, A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
MAKES THE DETERMINATION WHETHER
OR NOT TO NOTIFY THE PARENTS
BASED ON BOTH THE STUDENTS
RECORD AND THE STUDENTS ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION OF WHETHER THE
STUDENT BELIEVES NOTIFYING HIS
PARENT WILL ENDANGER THEIR
SAFETY. AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THE PARENT WILL BE NOTIFIED, BUT
IT'S PRIORITIZING THE CHILD AT
THAT MOMENT IN THAT TIME, FIRST
AND FOREMOST. SO NOT WHETHER OR
NOT SO THE CLAUSE WOULD BE WILL
ENDANGER THE CHILD. IF THE CHILD
STATES THAT IT WILL ENDANGER THE
CHILD, NOT NECESSARILY THAT
THERE IS CHILD ABUSE. WELL, IT'S
THE FIRST THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
POTENTIALLY BEING ABUSED OR
HAVING A DIFFICULTY OR SO FORTH.
IT'S HEARING DIRECTLY FROM THEM,
RIGHT. SO II. I HATE TO BRING
THIS CASE UP. BUT THERE THERE IS
A CASE THAT I'M WELL AWARE OF
WHERE THERE WAS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE FATHER WAS RAPING HER.
EIGHT YEARS OLD. AND UM, SHE WAS
GOING TO SCHOOL. ANONYMOUS
COMPLAINT CAME IN. UH, IT'S NOT
CLEAR EXACTLY WHO MADE THAT
COMPLAINT AND, UH SOCIAL WORKERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OBVIOUSLY
GET INVOLVED. IT'S A SERIOUS
CRIME. IT CAUSES A LOT OF HARM
AND SO FORTH AND THE PRIORITY MY
SISTER IS A SOCIAL WORKER AS
WELL, UM, IS TO ENGAGE AND SEE
AND ASSESS WHAT IS GOING ON.
RIGHT AND THAT IS TALKING TO THE
CHILD. ALSO EVENTUALLY TALKING
TO THE PARENT AS UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT IS THE HOME LIFE SITUATION
RIGHT, SO PARENTS ARE ALWAYS
STILL INVOLVED. BUT IF THE
PERPETRATOR OR THE VIOLATOR IS
THE PARENT IS CREATING HARM,
RIGHT IS ABUSIVE IN ANY MANNER,
THEN IT IS TREATED SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENTLY RIGHT BECAUSE THE
HARM IS THE PERSON THAT IT'S
REALLY CHARGED WITH PROTECTING
THE CHILD, SO IT'S FOLLOWING
THAT MODEL. AS FIRST AND
FOREMOST PROTECTING THE CHILD
AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS GOING
ON RIGHT? BECAUSE HOW ELSE WOULD
ANYBODY KNOW THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING? UNLESS THE CHILD
FINALLY SPEAKS UP? AND THAT IS
THE WHOLE POINT OF HAVING THIS
WHERE THE CHILD IS A DIRECTLY IS
THIS GOING TO CREATE A PROBLEM?
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS? YOU KNOW
WHAT IS YOUR CONCERN? WHAT IS
YOUR FEAR? IT IS VERY MUCH ON
THE CHILD'S LEVEL. AND SO THE
QUESTION THAT I WOULD ASK OR
FOLLOW UP WITH WOULD BE THE
BASIS FOR NOT INFORMING THE
PARENT WOULD THAT JUSTIFY
CURRENT ABUSE, SEXUAL OR
PHYSICAL ABUSE IF THERE IS
CURRENT OR SEXUAL ABUSE? AND
DECIDING WHETHER IN DECIDING NOT
TO INFORM THE PARENT. IS THAT
STILL IN PLACE? THERE IS A CHILD
HAVE TO STATE THAT THERE IS
PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL ABUSE OR JUST
IF THEY FEEL THERE'S A THREAT TO
SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL ABUSE HAPPEN
IF THEY WERE TO INFORM THE
PARENTS IF I COULD CLARIFY WHAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING NOW IS THE
PROTOCOL FOR THE INTERVENTION,
RIGHT? NOT NOT THE NOT THE
ULTIMATE SORT OF DISPOSITION,
RIGHT, SO AT SOME POINT OR
ANOTHER PARENTS WILL GET
INVOLVED SO 100% THAT IS
ACCURATE. AND THEN NUMBER TWO
AMANDA DICKEY HERE WE HAVE A
POLICY. LIKE THAT IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY, AND I JUST WANT HER TO
KIND OF ELABORATE AS TO WHAT IS
THE CURRENT PRACTICE IN
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY DOING
THIS WELL. STATE OR LOCAL. THIS
IS LOCAL, BUT OF COURSE, WE'RE
GONNA EVENTUALLY TRY TO ADOPT IT
IN THIS POLICY. SO I. I WISH
ACTUALLY THAT I COULD SAY THAT
THIS WAS A POLICY THAT WE HAVE
ADOPTED IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT, AND IT
VERY MUCH RELATES BACK TO
NATHAN'S SITUATION. YOU HEARD
HIM DISCUSS VERY CLEARLY THAT HE
WAS FACING ABUSE AT HOME. AND
THAT IS WHAT TRIGGERED THE
SUICIDAL IDEATION. UM IN HIS
INSTANCE. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS PREVENT EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED TO HIM FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN. THERE WERE SOME PRETTY
SEVERE CONSEQUENCES AS A RESULT
OF HIS PARENTS BEING NOTIFIED,
UM AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HOPING
TO AVOID. AND JUST JUST TO BE
CLEAR TO YOUR ANSWER. UM OR YOUR
QUESTION. UM SO RIGHT NOW, AND
I'M JUST SPEAKING FROM THE
SOCIAL SERVICES, UH, PERSPECTIVE
, RIGHT. UM LET'S SAY A CRISIS
WE COMMITTED IN A SCHOOL
BATHROOM AND, YOU KNOW, TEACHERS
CAME IN AND SO FORTH, OR A CHILD
HAD A BREAKDOWN OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. THE PROFESSIONAL
WOULD ASK WHAT IS GOING ON
ASSESSING THE HEALTH RISK SO
FORTH AND RIGHT NOW? SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE CALLED COUNTY, YOU
KNOW? UM UH UH èC P S¼ IS OFTEN
INVOLVED RIGHT FROM THE COUNTY
RIGHT NOW. AND A SOCIAL WORKER
WOULD GO IN SPECIFICALLY FROM
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND ASSESS.
OK WHAT IS GOING ON? HOW CAN WE
ADDRESS THIS? IS THERE ABUSE SO
THIS MAY BE THE VERY FIRST TIME?
LET'S SAY WHEN THE KID FINALLY
DOES SOMETHING RIGHT? THAT SHOWS
THAT I'VE HAD ENOUGH. I'M I'M
BREAKING DOWN. IT ALLOWS THE
SOCIAL WORKER AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL, SPECIFICALLY
THE THERAPIST AND SO FORTH AS
THE FIRST POINT TO TALK TO THE
CHILD. THAT IS THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL, RIGHT? AND TO ASSESS IS
SOMETHING GOING ON WHAT IS
BOTHERING YOU? IS IT SOMETHING
AT HOME? IS IT SOMETHING AT
SCHOOL? IF IT'S SOMETHING ELSE,
IF IT'S SOMETHING AT SCHOOL, YOU
KNOW CHILDREN CAN LARGELY, YOU
KNOW, SAY YES. YOU KNOW, I HAVE
TO TALK TO MY PARENT OR THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND OR SOMETHING.
IT MAY BE SOMETHING SMALL.
ANOTHER TIME. IT COULD BE. MY
PARENT IS DOING THIS OR MY AUNT
OR MY UNCLE OR MY GRANDFATHER.
RIGHT SO THAT IS WHAT IT IS NOW,
èC P S¼ GETS INVOLVED, LAW
ENFORCEMENT POTENTIALLY GETS
INVOLVED AND SO FORTH. THIS BILL
WILL JUST ALLOW FOR AGAIN.
PRIORITY IS NOT REALLY POLICE
OFFICERS, WHICH WE HAVE SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS. IT IS THE
THERAPIST. IT IS THE
PSYCHIATRIST, THE PSYCHOLOGIST
WHOEVER, BUT THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL THAT THE SCHOOLS
DESIGNATE. THAT IS WHAT THIS
BILL IS OVERALL DOING AS FAR AS
PARENTAL RIGHTS. THEY WILL
ALWAYS KNOW UNLESS THEY ARE
BEING POTENTIALLY THE ABUSER. IF
THAT IS THE CASE, AN
INVESTIGATION IS STILL DONE
BECAUSE IT'S A èC P S¼ CASE AT
THAT POINT, THIS IS JUST THE
FIRST POINT OF CONTACT WITH THE
CHILD. SO CLARIFICATION ONCE
AGAIN. THE PARENT WILL
EVENTUALLY KNOW EVENTUALLY NÓ,
BUT THE TIME FRAME IN WHICH THEY
WILL KNOW WILL ONLY BE, UM
INFORMED ABOUT THE WILL NOT BE
INFORMED IF THERE'S PHYSICAL OR
CURRENT SEXUAL ABUSE. YOU KNOW,
STATED BY THE CHILD? YES. THEY
WILL STILL BE INFORMED OF LIKE,
HEY, THIS IS WE HAVE CUSTODY OF
YOUR CHILD. THIS IS GOING ON.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION AND SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE NOT NECESSARILY ALLOWED TO
REMOVE THE CHILD IMMEDIATELY
RIGHT UNLESS THEY BELIEVE THERE
IS HARM AND THERE'S AN IMMINENT
THREAT RIGHT? AND THEY WORK HAND
IN HAND WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT ON
THAT. OK? OK, THANK YOU, I. I
ACTUALLY MR NÓ, YOU KNOW,
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY, BOTH
BRAVE AND ART, BUT I'LL BET YOU
HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD TO THIS
IF, IF YOU DON'T MIND. UM, IN
ESSENCE, UM, THE HARD AND CORE
OF THE BILL. IT'S MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN THERE IS A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS, THERE IS A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SPECIALIST OR
PROFESSIONAL TO MEET IT. UM I
FEEL LIKE THAT POINT OF LOGIC.
UM, AND THE REASON WHY WE'RE
PROPOSING THAT IS VERY, VERY
CLEAR. UM IF A MATTER IS MEDICAL
, UM OR IS OF A PHYSICAL NATURE,
YOU'D CALL IN A, UM, A SCHOOL
NURSE. PARAMEDIC A DOCTOR. YOU
WOULD NOT SEND LAW ENFORCEMENT
JUST BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
CLOSEST UM, THING TO A RESOURCE
YOU HAVE NEARBY. WE JUST ASK
THAT MENTAL HEALTH AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH BE TREATED THE EXACT SAME
WAY, ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE IS A
CRISIS. BUT A BIT MORE
CLARIFICATION WITH THE SENATOR'S
POINT. UM WHEN IT COMES TO
PARENTAL NOTIFICATION WITHIN
THIS BILL, ALL IT REALLY DOES
AND ADDS, UM AND BOLSTERS TO OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM WHEN NOTIFYING
PARENTS, UM IS THAT THE CHILD IS
CONSULTED IF NOTIFICATION WOULD
PUT THEM IN ANY DANGER. UM PART
OF SEEING IF THEY'RE IN ANY
DANGER TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCE, UM, ABUSE EITHER
ONGOING OR IN THE PAST. UM BUT
ALSO IF THE CHILD BELIEVES THAT
THE NOTIFICATION WILL TRIGGER
ABUSE OR HARM TO COME TO THEM.
THAT WOULD ALSO BE A FACTOR. UM,
CURRENT PRO STILL EXISTS WHERE,
UM, THE SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST CAN
LOOK AT THE RECORD. UM I THINK
THE SOCIAL RECORD OR ANY SCHOOL
RECORD INDICATING THAT THERE IS
ABUSE, BUT NOW THEY'RE ALSO
REQUIRED TO CONSULT. UM THE
YOUNG PERSON IN QUESTION AND
PARTICIPATE WITH THEM BECAUSE
THIS IS THEIR LIFE AT THE END OF
THE DAY, AND THEY DO DESERVE A
VOICE IN THE MATTER. I
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR, SENATOR
CORTES IS NOT THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. UM AND APPRECIATE, UM THE
QUESTION AND ANSWERS THAT BEEN
PROVIDED SO FAR IN ALWAYS
APPRECIATE HEARING FROM
COLLEAGUE WHO HAS SCHOOL BOARD
EXPERIENCE. UM AS AS, DO I, YOU
KNOW, GOING BACK SOME YEARS. WE
SHARE A LOT OF SANTA CLARK
COUNTY. THE AUTHOR, AND I, AND I
JUST WANTED TO SPEAK VERY
QUICKLY, UH, BEFORE JUST
INDICATING MY GENERAL SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. SANTA CLARA COUNTY
. I WOULD, I WOULD SAY,
ADMITTEDLY. UM IS SET UP. IS A
TRUE EXAMPLE OF BEST PRACTICES
RIGHT NOW AND I THINK PART OF
THE ISSUE IS NOT SO MUCH THAT
THAT COUNTY NEEDS IT PER S¼ E.
AS MUCH AS THIS REALLY NEEDS TO
BE SOMETHING THAT'S UM, POLICY
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. AND WHAT
I MEAN BY THAT IS THAT YOU KNOW,
I'VE BEEN A CHAMPION THIS AS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DOWN THERE FOR A
DOZEN YEARS, AND PRIOR TO THAT
GOING BACK ALL THE WAY TO MY
SCHOOL BOARD DAYS. WHAT IS
DEFINED IN THIS BILL AS
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS OR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. THE LEXICON.
THERE IS A SCHOOL LINK SERVICES
COORDINATORS. AND BASICALLY THE
IDEA IS THAT THE COUNTY AND THE
COUNTY AND THE, UM AS THE AUTHOR
HAS INDICATED THE COUNTY AND THE
UM SCHOOL PROFESSIONAL. ARE ABLE
TO SHARE INFORMATION AND THAT'S
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS MADE THAT
VERY DOABLE THROUGH LEGISLATION.
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
SO RATHER THAN HAVING TO TAKE A
STUDENT OFF SITE, AS WAS
DESCRIBED IN THE TESTIMONY MORE
OFTEN WITH THIS IDEA OF
INTERVENTION. PREVENTION. AND
THEN, AS A LAST RESORT
ENFORCEMENT, A STUDENT IS ABLE
TO BE BROUGHT INTO A SCHOOLING
SERVICES COORDINATOR WHO IS A
TRAINED PROFESSIONAL IS DEFINED
IN, UM, THE SENATOR'S BILL. AND
IN IMMEDIATE CHECK-IN CAN BE
DONE, WHICH WILL THEN LEAD TO
ALL OF THESE OTHER THINGS THAT I
APPRECIATED THE AUTHOR'S
RESPONSE. IN TERMS OF I MEAN, IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE? COUNTY AGENCY
INTERVENTION AT A CERTAIN LEVEL.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT IS GONNA
BE BEST SERVED TO HAVE THE
COUNTY. FOR EXAMPLE, COME IN, OR
SOME OTHER PROVIDER. AND MEET
WITH THAT FAMILY AND THE
STUDENT. IN DUE COURSE.
OFTENTIMES I HAVE FOUND WHERE
THIS IS DONE RIGHT? AND THIS
BILL WILL ASSURE THAT IT'S DONE
RIGHT IS THAT THE STUDENTS
RETURN TO THE CLASSROOM RIGHT
AWAY INSTEAD OF BEING HANDCUFFED
AND HAULED OFF UNLESS THERE'S
SUDDEN ONSET OF PSYCHOSIS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, THAT THAT
REQUIRES A STUDENT TO BE BROUGHT
TO AN OFFSET FACILITY. STUDENTS
ARE CHECKED IN WITH STUDENTS GET
RIGHT BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM.
ALL OF THIS IS DEALT WITH ON
SITE AND THEY CAN, UH,
SUBSEQUENTLY TYPICALLY HAVE THE
FAMILY COME IN, UH, NOT
NECESSARILY AN ABUSE SITUATIONS,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT HAVE THEM COME IN
TO DEAL WITH THIS? SO I'M A
PROUD CO-AUTHOR OF THE BILL. I
THINK IT'S JUST TAKING ALL THIS
WORK THAT SO MANY OF US,
INCLUDING PEOPLE SITTING ON THE
DAIS HERE HAVE BEEN DOING OVER
THE YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION IS
REALLY THE PRIORITY BEFORE YOU
START BRINGING IN BADGES AND
GUNS AND, YOU KNOW, TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THINGS LIKE THIS, UH,
ON THE ENFORCEMENT SIDE, SO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON
THIS, AND I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE
IT. MOVE THE BILL. I THINK, UM I
FORGET WHAT THE MOTION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE AS AMENDED AS
AMENDED AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
MR CHAIR. APPRECIATE IT. WE
WOULD JUST ACCEPTED. MOVE THE
BILL, SO THANK YOU, SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
KNOW THAT'S NOT AN EASY THING TO
DO TO BE VULNERABLE LIKE THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU SHARING. UH,
SO ON THE BILL WE'VE USED LIKE
EXTREME EXAMPLES OF PROTECTING
KIDS, AND I AND I AGREE WITH
THAT. FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO SAY
WE NEEDED. WE NEEDED THIS
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION EVEN
BEFORE COVID. UH, WHAT THESE
KIDS GO THROUGH TODAY IS JUST
IT'S REALLY IT'S REALLY HARD.
IT'S REALLY HEARTBREAKING. SO MY
QUESTION IS THIS AND I THINK IT
JUST PROBABLY COMES DOWN TO
COMMON SENSE. I THINK I'M FINE
WITH IT BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE
MOST KIDS FEAR THAT THEIR
PARENTS WON'T UNDERSTAND. AND SO
THEY MIGHT BE AFRAID TO SAY. OH,
I DON'T WANT MY YOU KNOW, MY MOM
TO KNOW MY DAD TO KNOW WHEN, IN
FACT THEIR PARENTS LOVE THEM
UNCONDITIONALLY AND NEED TO BE
INVOLVED. SO I'M ASSUMING THESE
PROFESSIONALS ARE GOING TO BE
USING COMMON SENSE, RIGHT, SO
LIKE THERE'S NOT NÓ ONE'S GONNA
BE HIDING THE BALL OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. SO I JUST WANT TO GO
ON THE RECORD WITH THAT FROM
YOU. SO THAT WAY I CAN SUPPORT
IT. UM YES, UH, THESE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE FULLY
TRAINED. THEY'RE TRAINED TO
SPEAK TO A MINOR TRAINED AT ALL
DIFFERENT AGES. THEY WORK FOR
OVER 3000 HOURS. JUST INTERNING
TO BE ABLE TO GAIN THE SKILL
SETS TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
AGAIN. PARENTS ARE NOTIFIED, BUT
IT THE FIRST QUESTION IS TO THE
CHILD. IT'S NOT JUST ARE YOUR
PARENTS GOING TO BE UPSET RIGHT?
CAUSE WE ALL KNOW A LOT OF
PARENTS AND KIDS ARE AFRAID THAT
YOU KNOW THEIR MOM AND DAD IS
GOING TO BE MAD AT THEM BECAUSE
THEY GOT A CALL FROM SCHOOL. THE
QUESTION IS, IS THERE GONNA BE
VIOLENCE OR ABUSE? OR LIKE SOME
TYPE OF, UM, EXCESSIVE, UH,
THING THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN TO
YOU, AND THAT'S A KID EVENTUALLY
SHARES AND THAT'S THE ASSESSMENT
STILL BASED ON THAT PROFESSIONAL
AND THEIR EXPERIENCE AND SO
FORTH. GREAT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, SO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATORS. SENATOR IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE. I MEAN, FOR MY PART
GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL. LET ME
JUST ALSO SAY NOT ONLY IS THIS A
SMART APPROACH, UM THIS IS PART
OF A LARGER TREND IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH THAT IT IS ABOUT DE
ESCALATION, WHICH IS ALL TO THE
GOOD SO AND I. I WILL ALSO SAY,
YOU KNOW, THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
MR GURO. BUT ESPECIALLY MR NÓ.
UH, YOU KNOW, IT IS NOT AN EASY
THING TO COME. YOU YOU WERE
BOTH, YOU KNOW, VERY ARTICULATE,
BUT ALSO TO SENATOR WILLS POINT
BRAVE TO DO THIS, UH, IF YOU'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU. UM I. I
GENERALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS. UM, I OFTEN JOKE WITH
A LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
THAT, UM I'M NOT A PARENT. SO I
KNOW YOU GUYS ARE LOOKING AT
THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE OUR
PARENTS ARE LOOKING AT A VERY
DIFFERENT LENS. BESIDES BEING A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER OR HAVING
SOME EXPERIENCE, UM, IN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM, I SPECIFICALLY
JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT THE STORY
THAT I WAS, UM, HALF SHARING
WITH YOU IN THE SENSE OF, UM
THOSE KIDS IMMEDIATELY. LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS INVOLVED.
PARENTS WERE IMMEDIATELY TOLD SO
FORTH. THEY WERE RETURNED TO
THEIR HOUSEHOLD. WHERE ABUSE
CONTINUED AND THE CHILDREN WHO
AGAIN UNDER THE AGE OF 10 WERE
ASKED, LIKE, IS THIS TRUE? AND
THEY HAD YOU KNOW ALL THEIR
ELDERS COME IN AND SO FORTH, AND
THEY RECANTED THEIR STORY.
BECAUSE OF THE PRESSURE FROM
THEIR FAMILY. RIGHT THAT THIS
CAN'T BE TRUE. MY BROTHER CAN'T
DO THIS. MY SON CAN'T DO THIS.
YOUR FATHER COULDN'T HAVE DONE
THIS TO YOU. AND THE ABUSE
CONTINUED, AND THEY RECANTED
THEIR STORY BECAUSE THEIR MOTHER
UH, WAS UNDOCUMENTED. AND THE
AUNTS OF THE SISTERS OF THE
HUSBAND WAS BASICALLY USING THAT
SAYING I WILL NOT SUPPORT HER.
SHE WILL BE KICKED OUT ON THE
STREET. YOUR FATHER'S GOING TO
JAIL. YOU WILL HAVE NÓ HOME, XY
AND Z. OF THE WORST OF THE WORST
TO AN EIGHT YEAR OLD. AND THE
ABUSE CONTINUED FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS. AND THEY'RE FULL GROWN
ADULTS WITH KIDS OF THEIR OWN.
NOW UM THEIR FATHER PASSED AWAY.
AND THEY SAY THAT THAT WAS THE
MOST PIVOTAL. MOMENT IN THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE. THAT COULD HAVE
PREVENTED YEARS OF ABUSE AND
TRAUMA. AND IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
BECAUSE THEY GOT PRESSURE
IMMEDIATELY TO BE RETURNED TO
THEIR ABUSER WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION THAT THIS IS THE
END ALL BE ALL THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING. THIS IS MY LIMIT AT
EIGHT YEARS OLD. AND SO, YES,
CHILDREN ARE CHILDREN, AND MOST
KIDS ARE AFRAID THAT THEIR
PARENTS ARE GOING TO BE UPSET OR
OR NOT, UM, AND YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A LOT OF FAMILIES THAT
ARE GONNA BE UPSET IF THEY GET A
CALL FROM SCHOOL, BUT ABUSE IS
VERY DIFFERENT, AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. IF A KID IS
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY'RE
WANTING TO COMMIT SUICIDE. SOME
TYPE OF EXTRA INTERVENTION NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE IN THE WELL BEING
AND EFFORT AND FOCUS OF THAT
CHILD, FIRST AND FOREMOST. AND
OF COURSE, THE PARENTS ARE
INFORMED AND IT'S HANDLED
APPROPRIATELY SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN EYE FOR ALL THE KIDS
WHO ARE STILL TOO AFRAID TO
SHARE THEIR STORY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. WE HAVE MET WITH
SOMETHING. PLEASE CALL THE WHILE
A AND FOR S¼ B 1318 WHA MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN. I Ó TO B¢O. CORTESE
CORTESE. I GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
MARWOOD WE, WILK WILK. THE
MEASURE HAS THREE VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
TO THE WITNESSES. AND LET US SEE
WHERE WE ARE. I UNDERSTAND.
SENATOR HURTADO WAS HAVING SOME
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. NOT SURE
IF THAT'S BEEN RESOLVED.
OTHERWISE NEXT FILE WOULD BE
SENATOR GONZALEZ, WHO'S NOT YET
PRESENT. LET US THEN. TAKE A
MOMENT AND I THINK WE'LL MOVE.
YEAH. THIS IS A POINT OF
INFORMATION I AM PREPARED TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HURTADO. I'M SURE THAT'S GOOD.
THEN WHY DON'T WHY DON'T WE DO
THAT NOW? SO WE, CORTES OK? THAT
IN ORDER, MR CHAIR WHILE UH
SENATOR CORTESE IS COMING UP.
CAN WE VOTE ON THE FIRST BILL
THAT WE HEARD THIS MORNING? A
TRICK QUESTION. YES SENATOR.
BECAUSE WE I UNDERSTAND A
SUBCOMITTEE. YOU HAVE PLACES TO
GO. I DO HAVE WE'RE STILL GONNA
HAVE TO CLOSE THIS OUT LATER.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE IN MY WE
DON'T WE HAVE THE SAME PLACE TO
GO. BUT I, I HERE YOU'LL GET TO
GO THERE. SO, MADAM èC, IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CALLING THE ROLL
ON, UH S¼ B 1491 SENATOR MONS
FILE ITEM FIVE S¼ B 1491 MON
MOTION IS DUE PASS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN. I Ó SORRY. IT'S ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. WE'RE GOING
SLIGHTLY OUT OF WORK. FIVE. YES.
ONE SEC. OH ARE WE GOING? DO WE
HEAR UNIFORM? WE HEARD THAT
FIRST. OH, SORRY. GIVE ME A
SECOND. WHAT WHILE YOU'RE DOING
THIS, LET ME VERY QUICKLY,
SENATOR. A èC B¢O NÓ. CORTESE
CORTESE. I GLASER GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, WILK, WILK NÓ.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR CORTEZ, ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR HURTADO,
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR IN SENATORS I PRESENTING
S¼ B 1048, AS WAS SAID ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR TOO. UM THE SENATOR
WANTS TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
AND GUIDANCE ON THIS BILL. SHE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. UH SO I STAND BEFORE
YOU TODAY. ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HURTADO. BUT ONCE AGAIN WITH A
HEAVY HEART PRESENTING A BILL
ABOUT THE LOSS OF LIFE OF ONE OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. UM THIS BILL
1048 IS ALSO KNOWN AS JOSHUA'S
LAW. THE BILL WAS NAMED IN HONOR
OF JOSHUA ROBINSON, A 12 YEAR
OLD WHO TRAGICALLY LOST HIS LIFE
AT CANDY LAKE MIDDLE SCHOOL
WHILE PARTICIPATING IN A
PHYSICAL EDUCATION DURING AN
EXTREME HEAT SITUATION. JOSHUA'S
LAW REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ESTABLISH STATEWIDE GUIDELINES
AND REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES. SO THAT
SCHOOLS CAN IMPLEMENT A STANDING
FRAMEWORK TO BETTER PROTECT
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY DURING ALL
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS.
THROUGH YOSHUA S¼ LAW. WE'RE
COMMITTING OURSELVES TO ENSURING
THAT NÓ FAMILY GOES THROUGH THIS
TRAGIC EXPERIENCE DUE TO
INADEQUATE PROTECTION AT OUR
SCHOOLS DURING EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS. RECENT RESEARCH HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
NOT ONLY AFFECTS THE ENVIRONMENT
AROUND US BUT IT'S ALSO IT ALSO
HAS DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON OUR
HEALTH, OF COURSE, WITH CHILDREN
BEING PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE,
ESPECIALLY THOSE OUTDOORS.
DESPITE THE GROWING EVIDENCE AND
THE INCREASING FREQUENCY OF
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS OR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BACK UNIFORM STANDARDS
TO PROTECT STUDENTS DURING
OUTDOOR ACTIVITIES. THIS GAP
LEAVES OUR CHILDREN EXPOSED
VULNERABLE AND AT RISK THE LACK
OF PREPAREDNESS ACROSS OUR
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
EXACERBATES THIS ISSUE, CREATING
AN URGENT NEED FOR SAFEGUARDS TO
ENSURE STUDENT SAFETY DURING
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS. OUR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY, OF COURSE,
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY THAT'S
WOVEN IN THE FABRIC OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. I THINK WE
ALL AGREE TO THAT. WE MUST
PROVIDE STATEWIDE GUIDANCE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY SCHOOL IS
EQUIPPED TO BETTER PROTECT
STUDENTS DURING THESE EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS AS PART OF
THAT PRIORITY. S¼ B 1248 DOES
JUST THAT BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ESTABLISH STATEWIDE GUIDELINES
IN CONSULTATION WITH RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPERTS SO THAT
OUR SCHOOLS CAN PRIORITIZE OUR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AGAIN DURING
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS WITH
US TODAY WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES,
CHRISTINA ASOR, WHO'S BEEN
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF THE
ROBINSON FAMILY. AND CHENEY
ROBINSON, WHO IS THE MOTHER OF
JOSHUA ROBINSON, WE APPRECIATE
THEM BEING HERE, MR CHAIR. I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE ROBINSONS. PLEASE
PROCEED. CAN YOU GUYS HEAR? YEAH
VERY WELL, I. I AM CHRISTINA
LASTER. GREETINGS UH SENATORS
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OF
CALIFORNIA. UM, AS AN ADVOCATE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT I USE MY VOICE
FREQUENTLY TO SPEAK UP ON BEHALF
OF THOSE WHO FEEL VOICELESS. UM
TODAY THE GREATEST SITUATION
LIES BEFORE ME, BUT THIS IS A
CONSTITUENT LED EFFORT AS
REFLECTIVE OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS
BEHIND ME THAT, UM, ARE ALSO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT DEEPLY
ABOUT CHILDREN. I WON'T TAKE TOO
MUCH TIME BECAUSE I'D RATHER
ALLOW THE VOICE OF THE PARENTS
TO COME FORWARD. BUT I DO ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER SERIOUSLY,
THAT COMMUNITY THAT BANNED CAME
TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN IN
A REALITY FOR ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN, UM, AND THAT YOU WOULD
PASS. S¼ B 1248. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MRS ROBERTSON. WELCOME
GREETING. SENATORS, UM EDUCATION
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES. MY FAMILY
AND FRIENDS HAVE TRAVELED OVER
EIGHT HOURS TO BE HERE. I'M JANA
WASHINGTON ROBINSON, MOTHER OF
LATE, GREAT YESHUA, NERI
ROBINSON. OUR FOREVER 12 YEAR
OLD. I AM ALSO A CALIFORNIA
STATE CLEAR CREDENTIALED.
PHYSICAL EDUCATION TEACHER. WITH
OVER 20 YEARS OF SERVICE EIGHT
OF THOSE YEARS WITHIN LAKE SNORE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. THE
SAME DISTRICT THAT I BELIEVE,
AND I FEEL STRONGLY KILLED OUR
SON. EACH DAY SINCE OUR SON'S
TRAGIC DEATH, WE'VE EXPERIENCED
A RANGE OF EMOTIONS, FEELINGS OF
DESPAIR, GRIEF, INDIGNATION AND
MAINLY BETRAYAL. BY MY
COLLEAGUES AND THE VERY SYSTEM I
HAVE DEDICATED MY LIFE TO
SERVING CHILDREN. AND AN IMMENSE
AND INCAPABLE I THINK ABOUT HOW
WE TEACH CHILDREN TO FOLLOW
DIRECTIONS. MOST SYSTEMS OF
REWARDS AND CONSEQUENCES. ARE
BASED ON THEIR ABILITY TO FOLLOW
DIRECTIONS, BUT IT WAS NOT BAD.
FOR THEM TO FOLLOW DIRECTIONS.
THAT ON THAT EXTREMELY HOT DAY
IN AUGUST OF 2020 THREE, BECAUSE
OUR SON WAS TAKEN FROM US TOO
SOON. HIS LIFE WAS CUT SHORT
BECAUSE HE FOLLOWED DIRECTIONS
AND RAN IN THE HEAT. THEY WERE
FOR EDUCATION, PHYSICAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AT KENYON
LAKE MIDDLE SCHOOL THAT DAY. TH
HAS REPORTED THAT TWO OF THEM
WE'RE OUTSIDE. ENGAGING IN
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY IN THAT
EXTREME HEAT. I TOO, WAS WITH MY
SECOND GRADE STUDENTS 10 MINUTES
AWAY, BUT INSIDE SAFE FROM THE
EXCESSIVE HEAT. BECAUSE I FOLLOW
THE HEAT WARNING THAT I RECEIVED
ON MY CELL PHONE. FIVE TEACHERS
THE SAME DISTRICT NÓ COHESIVE
PLAN ACROSS THE DISTRICT. PLENTY
OF NEWS REPORTS ABOUT THE WEEK
LONG HEAT WAVE WERE ISSUED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SOME OF US
TOOK PRECAUTIONS OTHERS DID NOT.
AND THEIR PROOF CHOICES LED TO
OUR SON'S UNTIMELY DEATH. IT WAS
IN THE NINETIES OUTSIDE THAT DAY
, AND EVEN THE BEST AND HIGHLY
TRAINED ATHLETES WOULDN'T RUN IN
IT. YEP. YESHUA'S CLASS. OF
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS WERE MADE TO
RUN IN THAT HEAT. PHYSICAL
EDUCATION SHOULD HAPPEN ONLY IN
ENVIRONMENTS CONDUCIVE FOR
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY. AND UNLIKE
OTHER EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENTS,
OUR MAIN CLASSROOMS ARE OUTSIDE
AND IN THAT HOT HEAT AND IN THAT
EXTREME COLD THE GOAL IS TO
TEACH CHILDREN HOW TO BE WELL
ROUNDED, NOT UNSAFE. NÓ PARENT
LIKE US. WANTS TO BE BE THE ONE
WHO HAS TO OUTLIVE OUR CHILDREN.
AND NÓ PARENTS SENDS THEIR CHILD
TO SCHOOL WITHOUT EXPECTING HIM
NOT TO RETURN HOME. YESHUA DID
NOT COME BACK HOME. FROM SCHOOL
THAT DAY. THIS IS THE REALITY WE
NOW MUST LIVE WITH. WE RECOGNIZE
NOTHING WE CAN DO CAN BRING HIM
BACK OR MAKE THE PAIN OF LOSING
HIM GO AWAY. AS I SEE HIM DIE
EVERY DAY. WE ALL MISS HIM
DEARLY. WE URGE YOU TO PASS THIS
BILL SO THAT WHAT'S PREVENTABLE
WILL BE ADDRESSED AND PREVENTING
AL ALLOWING OTHER CHILDREN TO BE
SAFE. YESHUA WAS SO FULL OF LOVE
AND JOY. HE LOVES SPREADING HIS
JOY, PUTTING SMILES ON
EVERYONE'S FACE. THIS SHOULD BE
THE WAY HE IS REMEMBERED. PLEASE
PASS AND WE URGE YOU TO PASS
THIS BILL. SO HE TOLD US A
LITTLE SAYING I AM HIM. NOW I
KNOW MY SON HAD TO DIE. SO OTHER
CHILDREN CAN HAVE A CHANCE TO
LIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY ON.
I'M SORRY. SO SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS. UH, HAS ANYBODY HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE HEARING LIKE TO
TRY ON BEHALF OF THE MEASURE? IF
SO, PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONES, PLEASE. STATE YOUR
NAME? UH, YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL I. I
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B 1248,
AND I URGE YOU TO PASS IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS LAST YEAR
NEXT, PLEASE. MIA LEMAN
REPRESENTATIVE DE FAMIL IN PODER
ER, ESTÁ MENZA AND ESPANOL SOLEE
PARA LINGUISTIC AND CANARA
PROXIMA. DE PODER A POLL LÀ LADY
JOSHUA, JUST YOUR POSITION. I
APPRECIATE IT, GRAS. WE SUPPORT.
UM LÀ JOSHUA'S LÀ. THIS IS FILAS
AND POLA. ESPECIALLY BECAUSE, UM
, THE HOT WATER IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS SO HIGH. I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELCOME MY NAME IS
CAMERON WILSON. I'M A PARENT IN
THE LAKE ELSINORE SCHOOL UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I'M ASKING AND
I'M PRAYING AND I'M URGING YOU
TO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
WELL AS TO PASS IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'M WILMA WASHINGTON.
I'M THE GRANDMOTHER. AUA
ROBINSON AND I SUPPORT IN ASKING
YOU TO PLEASE PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN CONDOLENCES
FOR YOUR LOSS. NEXT PLEASE. I AM
A LITTLE ERIC ROBINSON. UM I'M
NOT SURE HIS OLDER BROTHER AND I
ASKED IF YOU CAN SUPPORT THE
LAW, PLEASE. THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. I'M
AMAYA BANKS. I'M YU'S OLDER
SISTER. AND, UM, I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY NAME IS TARYN. I'M HIS
COUSIN AND WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT BILL 1248. THANK YOU.
THANKS, PLEASE. ENRON DAVIS. I'M
HIS COUSIN. AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU, MR
DAVIS. HØI GOOD MORNING. UM
MYESHA DAVIS. I AM ASU'S AUNTIE.
I SUP. I URGE THAT YOU GUYS
SUPPORT THE BILL 1240. HELLO I'M
SARAH COLEMAN. I'M A PARENT AND
AN EDUCATOR IN THE P UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HØI. MY NAME IS
VERONICA GRIFFIN AND I'M ALSO AN
EDUCATOR IN THE SAME SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHERE JOSHUA LOST HIS
LIFE. AND I URGE YOU TO PASS
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS BRIAN
WILSON. UM I'M A PARENT IN THAT
AREA. I'M ALSO A BUSINESS OWNER.
AND I ASKED, UH, THAT YOU GUYS
DO WHAT YOU CAN TO PASS THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, SIR. MY NAME IS
LENNA HARRIS. I'M HIS BIG BRO.
UH, I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. MISTER PRESIDENT. MY NAME
IS DANIEL ASKER. I WAS HIS OLD
FRIEND AND I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I'M UH MARTIN
WASHINGTON. I'M JOSHUA'S
GRANDFATHER. AND I HOPE THAT YOU
CAN DO THIS FOR US. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MISTER. AND AGAIN
CONDOLENCES TO THE WHOLE FAMILY.
AND EVERYBODY FOR THE LOSS. HAS
ANYBODY ELSE IS GOING TO BE HERE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AT
SEEING NAN, LET US COME BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES. SECRET THANK YOU
FOR STEPPING IN ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HURTADO, SENATOR BOAT.
JUST IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE THESE TYPES OF
INCIDENTS IN ORDER TO MOVE
FORWARD LEGISLATION ON IT. I'M
SORRY THAT WE WERE NOT PROACTIVE
ON THAT MEASURE. UM BUT I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE, UM, THE
BILL FORWARD. I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND FOR MY PART AGAIN, UM PROOF.
TOO LATE THAT THIS IS NECESSARY.
IT'S KIND OF STRIKING. ME I
SERVED IN THE U S¼ MILITARY IN
THE EIGHTIES, WE HAD HEAT
PROTOCOLS THAT WERE UNIFORM
ACROSS, UH, THE WHOLE MILITARY
AND WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN OUT
IN WEATHER LIKE THAT WHICH IS
KIND OF IRONIC AND SAD. SENATOR
CORTESE WITH A MOTION IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR, AND, UM AND I,
TOO, ESPECIALLY ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HURTADO WANTED TO THANK
THE WITNESSES. FOR FIRST OF ALL
FOR TRAVELING TO BE HERE ALL THE
WAY FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY. UM,
SECONDLY, FOR YOUR COURAGE, UM,
WE UNDERSTAND THE PAIN YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH. OBVIOUSLY, WE
CANNOT FEEL IT. UM, IN THE SAME
MANNER THAT YOU DO. BUT IT IS
UNDERSTOOD. AND WITH THAT, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE AND THANK YOU, MADAM
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. F ITEM THREE S¼ B 1248
HURTADO MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN. I Ó I Ó I, CORTES
CORTESE I GLASER GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS WHILK. LOOK, I
VERY GOOD SO AGAIN THAT THAT
THAT MEASURE HAS VOTES AT THE
MOMENT IT WILL PASS. WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO
COME IN AND TAKE A VOTE. BUT
AGAIN, UH THANK YOU TO THE
FAMILY. UH THANK YOU FOR DOING
YOUR PART TO MAKE CALIFORNIA A
BETTER PLACE. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE IT. ALL RIGHT. SO
WELCOME TO SENATOR GONZALEZ. I
UNDERSTAND YOU WANNA YOU WANNA
DO YOU WANNA GO NOW? OR DO YOU
WANNA GO TO LAST? OK I
APPRECIATE THAT. SO, SO NEXT UP,
WE WILL HAVE S¼ B 991 FROM
SENATOR GONZALEZ, FOLLOWED BY S¼
B 1182 ALSO FROM THE SENATOR.
UH, I ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO
PRESENT ANOTHER BILL IN SANITY.
Q UH, SO, SENATOR OBO, IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND TAKING THE GAVEL,
UH AND I WOULD BE BACK AS SOON
AS I CAN.
WELCOME SENATOR GONZALEZ. UM,
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING S¼ B 991.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND BEFORE I BEGIN, I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS, WHICH
WILL REQUIRE THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT'S OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL TO SUBMIT
AN ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND REQUIRE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL BE APPOINTED
BY THE LAU S¼ Dð BOARD OF
EDUCATION FOR A THREE YEAR TERM.
SO S¼ B 991 WILL REMOVE THE 2025
SUNSET DATE FROM CURRENT STATE
TO ALLOW THE LU Dð OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO CONTINUE
ITS TRANSPARENT OVERSIGHT,
RESPONSIBILITIES AND PERPETUITY.
A DISTRICT IS LARGE AND DIVERSE
AS LAU S¼ Dð IS EXTREMELY UNIQUE
AND DESERVES SPECIAL ATTENTION
TO ENSURE THERE IS NÓ WASTE
FRAUD OR ABUSE IN RECOGNITION OF
THIS FACT AND TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE LEGISLATURE GRANTED THE
DISTRICT THE AUTHORITY TO
CONDUCT AUDITS, INVESTIGATIONS
IN 1999, AND FOR OVER TWO
DECADES, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
HAS MAINTAINED THE ABILITY TO
SUBPOENA WITNESSES ADMINISTER
OATHS OR AFFIRMATIONS, TAKE
TESTIMONY AND COMPEL THE
PRODUCTION OF INFORMATION WHEN
THERE IS A REASONABLE SUSPICION
THAT A LAW REGULATION OR POLICY
HAS BEEN VÚI THIS AUTHORITY HAS
BEEN EXTENDED MULTIPLE TIMES,
WITH THE MOST RECENT EXTENSION
BEING SIGNED INTO LAW IN 2014 S¼
B 991 SIMPLY REMOVES THE 2025
SUNSET DATE AND A LOUSY
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO CONTINUE
ITS TRANSPARENT OVERSIGHT.
RESPON AND TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. TODAY, I HAVE
SUE STANGEL. THE CURRENT LAU S¼
Dð, INSPECTOR GENERAL, AND
MARTHA ALVAREZ, CHIEF OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR LAU S¼
Dð TO ASSIST WITH TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE OF S¼ B 991. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, AND WE WELCOME
THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OF S¼
B 991, PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF. MY
NAME IS SUE STENGEL. AND SINCE
2022 I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING AS THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
FOR THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I'M HERE TODAY
TO SUPPORT S¼ B 991 A BILL TO
REAUTHORIZE THE LAU S¼ Dð S¼
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL ALSO
REFERRED TO AS THE OIG. OVER 25
YEARS AGO, THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
THE STATE LEGISLATURE PARTNERED
TO CREATE THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR LAU S¼ Dð
AS A PILOT. SINCE THEN, THE OIG
HAS SERVED HONORABLY AS A
STEWARD FOR PUBLIC TRUST,
HOLDING THE DISTRICT ACCOUNTABLE
FOR EFFICIENT COST EFFECTIVE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AND TO
PREVENT DETECT, IDENTIFY, EXPOSE
AND ELIMINATE POTENTIAL FRAUD,
WASTE AND ABUSE. THE WORK OF OUR
OFFICE INCLUDES AUDITING
DISTRICT CONTRACTS, PROGRAMS AND
OPERATIONS AND INVESTIGATING
SUSPECTED MISCONDUCT, BOTH
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CRIMINAL.
FURTHERMORE OUR OFFICE MANAGES
THE DISTRICT'S 24 7
WHISTLEBLOWER HOTLINE. EACH YEAR
. OUR OFFICE CONDUCTS A
COMPREHENSIVE RISK ASSESSMENT OF
DISTRICT CONTRACTS AND PROGRAMS
IN ACCORDANCE WITH GOVERNMENT
AUDITING STANDARDS AND BEST
PRACTICES TO DETERMINE OUR AUDIT
PLAN FOR THE UPCOMING FISCAL
YEAR. OUR WORK PLAN IS VETTED BY
BOTH THE BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
THE DISTRICT'S BOND OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE AT PUBLIC MEETINGS,
AND THE WORK PLAN IS PUBLISHED
IN ADVANCE OF THESE MEETINGS FOR
THE PUBLIC'S REVIEW. ACCORDING
TO THE STATEMENT OF PRINCIPLES
FOR OFFICES OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
, WE SERVE THE PUBLIC BEST WHEN
WE FOLLOW THE BASIC PRINCIPLES
OF INTEGRITY, OBJECTIVITY,
INDEPENDENCE AND
CONFIDENTIALITY, AMONG OTHERS.
WE STRONGLY PROTECT OUR
INDEPENDENCE BEING FREE FROM
PERSONAL IMPAIRMENTS AND
EXTERNAL INFLUENCES, BOTH IN
FACT, AND IN APPEARANCE ENSURES
THAT OUR OPINIONS, CONCLUSIONS,
JUDGMENTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE IMPARTIAL AND ARE VIEWED BY
OTHERS AS IMPARTIAL. THE
INTEGRITY OF AN INVESTIGATION IS
DEPENDENT ON CONFIDENTIALITY
WHEN PARTIES TO AN INVESTIGATION
ARE PREMATURELY NOTIFIED OF OUR
INTEREST. THIS CREATES THE
POTENTIAL FOR COLLUSION,
DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE,
REHEARSING OF STORIES OR
OBSTRUCTION. CONFIDENTIALITY
INSTILLS CONFIDENCE IN OUR WORK
PROTECTS THOSE WHO MAKE REPORTS
TO US AND REDUCES THE LIKELIHOOD
OF RETALIATION AGAINST
COMPLAINANTS AND WITNESSES. IN
THE LAST SIX YEARS, OIG
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATIONS HAVE
RESULTED IN 39 CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS FOR CHARGES RANGING
FROM LARCENY AND WIRE FRAUD TO
CONSPIRACY TO EMBEZZLE PUBLIC
FUNDS. DURING 2020 THREE ALONE,
THE OIG IDENTIFIED $6.5 MILLION
IN MONETARY BENEFITS AS A RESULT
OF AUDITS, INVESTIGATIONS AND
TECHNICAL EVALUATIONS. IN SHORT,
WE HOLD THE DISTRICT TO HIGH
STANDARDS AND OURSELVES TO
HIGHER STANDARDS. THIS
GUARANTEES TRUST IN OUR WORK AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY, TRUST IN THE
WORK OF THE DISTRICT TO EDUCATE
STUDENTS. FOR THESE REASONS. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON SENATE
BILL 991 TO AUTHORIZE THE OIG TO
EXIST PERMANENTLY. BY DOING SO
YOU WILL SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
DEDICATED TO PROMOTING
TRANSPARENCY AND ENSURING THAT
LAU S¼ Dð SERVES THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES IT SERVES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MARTHA ALVAS,
CHIEF OF GOVERN NATION FOR THE
L, A UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT, AS
ANOTHER CONFERENCE MENTIONED,
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT WHO IS NOT ABLE
TO ANSWER. UH WE WERE SURE I
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR OUR KEY LEAD. WITNESSES
WILL NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OF SB 991
HERE IN ROOM 2100. SEEING NÓ
MORE CONTINUE TO, UH, ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO S¼ B
991 HERE ROOM 2100. BY SHARING,
UH, MEMBERS. JOHN WINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION. UH, WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSING
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION BUT
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
STAFF AND THE SPONSORS, UH, FOR
THE CONTINUED DIALOGUE, AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. UM WE HAVE
CONCERNS, PARTICULARLY AROUND.
UH, HOW THE OIG IN THE PAST, AS
HAS HAD SOME BEHAVIOR RELATED TO
CHARTER SCHOOL RENEWALS AND
REVOCATIONS, UM AS AN EXAMPLE IN
2014. THE L, A USD ATTEMPTED TO
CLOSE A FEW HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOLS BASED ON
INFORMATION THAT HAD NEVER BEEN
MADE PUBLIC OR HAD LATER BEEN
FOUND TO BE INCOMPLETE FROM AN
Ó. I REPORT UM THIS CAUSE THOSE
SCHOOLS TO SUE RESULT IN A IN A
PRELIMINARY INJUNCTION TO KEEP
THE SCHOOLS OPEN AND LATER THERE
WAS A LATER SETTLEMENT TO
CONTINUE TO REAUTHORIZE THOSE
SCHOOLS. BUT IN 2015, THE BUREAU
OF UH, STATE AUDITS CONDUCTED AN
AUDIT OF THE SITUATION AND FOUND
SEVERAL FINDINGS THAT WERE
CONCERNING TO US, PARTICULARLY
IT FOUND THAT NOT ONLY HAD THE
CHARTER SCHOOL BEEN UNABLE TO
ACCESS THE REPORT, BUT THE Ó I
HAD DENIED A U Dð OWN CHARTER
SCHOOL DIVISION ACCESS TO THE
DOCUMENT. BECAUSE OF ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE. THE Ó IG ALSO
HAD DRAFTED A MEMO BASED ON THE
DRAFT REPORT, AND THEY GAVE THAT
TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL DIVISION.
AND THAT WAS FOUND TO BE
INACCURATE. UH FINALLY, THE
CHARTER SCHOOL IN QUESTION WAS
NEVER ALLOWED TO SEE OR COMMENT
ON THE DRAFT FINDINGS OR ATTEMPT
TO CURE THE PROBLEMS THEY
IDENTIFIED. UH AND Ó IG
CANCELED PHASE TWO OF THAT
REPORT, WHICH WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
THE CHARTER SCHOOL TO COMMENT,
AND SO, UH, WE HAD A SITUATION
WHERE YOU KNOW, THREE CHARTER
SCHOOLS WERE ATTEMPTED TO BE
SHUT DOWN. WITHOUT A REPORT THAT
WAS MADE PUBLIC AND SO WE WANT
TO CONTINUE SOME DISCUSSIONS
AROUND JUST WHAT WE CAN DO, UH
AROUND TRANSPARENCY AND JUST
ENSURING THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN. IN THE FUTURE. IT'S NOT
AN INDICTMENT ON THE CURRENT OIG
OR WHAT THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING
AROUND THEIR BROADER WORK, BUT,
UH, IF THE SUNSET IS REMOVED
INDEFINITELY, I THINK WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOME SOME PARAMETERS
PUT AROUND THE TRANSPARENCY
PROVISIONS, AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, UM, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER KEY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO 991? WE'LL PROCEED
WITH ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO 991 HERE IN ROOM 2100. èC  N
N WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DÍAS ANY QUESTIONS? COMMENTS
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. SO WHAT?
WHAT'S YOUR CURRENT BUDGET? I
HAVEN'T LOOKED IN A LONG TIME.
BUT LIKE THE LAST TIME I LOOKED,
IT WAS $10.3 BILLION. SO DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE CURRENT, UH,
BUDGET IS? UH, YES. GOOD MORNING
. UM FOR THE FOR OR SPEAKING.
ROBERT L UNIFIED OR THE Ó IG TO
CLARIFY? YES UM, SO THE L A
UNIFIED BUDGET IS APPROXIMATELY
10 POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
OF BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS.
OBVIOUSLY UH, ORGANIZATION OF
THAT MAGNITUDE NEEDS NEEDS TO
HAVE OVERSIGHT, AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION, BUT THAT WAS A
PRIOR. UH AUDITORS. SO UM, I
GUESS MY QUESTION FOR YOU
BECAUSE I SEE THE NEED FOR THIS.
UM ARE YOU GONNA CONTINUE TO
HAVE DIALOGUE WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
TRANSPARENCY COMPONENTS ARE IN
PLACE? YES, ABSOLUTELY, OF
COURSE. AND THANK YOU. AND I
KNOW YOU'VE WORKED ON THIS PRIOR
SO OK, GREAT. SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. AND
WE'LL MOVE IT WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL. DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS? UM, I DO
HAVE A QUESTION AND THEN I'LL
PASS THE G, UH, TO OUR CHAIRMAN,
UM, I DO HAVE A QUESTION. UM
ALONG WITH, UH, SENATOR ROOK. I
ALSO WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS. I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
BUT I DO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
LOOK AT THE FINAL LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE SAFETY.
UH PROTOCOL OR TRANSPARENCY
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE TO ENSURE I
DID HAVE A QUESTION, THOUGH. UH
WITH REGARDS TO THE DEPARTMENT
IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS, SUCH AS
THE ONE THAT WAS EXPRESSED TODAY
BY THE OPPOSITION, UH, WITH
REGARDS TO THE PROCESS, UH,
PERHAPS NOT BEING, UM DONE IN A
IN A RIGHT MANNER. AS THE
AUDITORS POINTED OUT, WHAT IS
THE RECOURSE TO THOSE PARTIES
AND WHO? WHO DO THEY GO TO, UH,
MAKE A COMPLAINT OR HAVE THE
SITUATION BE EVALUATED? WHO?
WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP UP? I GUESS
YOU COULD SAY THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND IF I CAN DEFER TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND OUR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS TEAM SO, UM
, I CANNOT SPEAK TO WHAT
HAPPENED. UM, BACK SEVERAL YEARS
AGO. I DO WANT TO ENSURE, UM,
THE COMMITTEE THAT OUR OFFICE
IS, UM IS VERY DEDICATED TO
TRANSPARENCY. THE ISSUE OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT OPERATING
UNDER THE STANDARDS AND
PRINCIPLES FOR INSPECTORS.
GENERAL TRANSPARENCY IS ONE OF
THE MAIN TENANTS, UM, OF OUR
ROLES. UM AND SO IS INDEPENDENCE
. AND AS I STATED BEFORE, WE
NEED TO BE INDEPENDENT FROM ANY
OUTSIDE, UM, OR INTERNAL
INFLUENCES SO THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS CONFIDENCE IN OUR WORK. I
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE, UH, THOSE
EFFORTS AND THOSE THOSE
PRINCIPLES, BUT I'M STILL IT
DOESN'T QUITE ANSWER MY QUESTION
AS TO IF THERE IS A, UM MOVING
FORWARD WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION. PER S¼ E, BUT IT
WITHIN THE SYSTEM IF THERE IS A
QUESTION WITH REGARD TO THE
OUTCOME, OR THE CALIBER OR THE
TYPE OF INVESTIGATION THAT WAS
CONDUCTED. WHAT'S NEXT? WHERE DO
WE GO AFTER THAT, UM, AS FAR AS
TRYING TO, UM RECONSIDER WHAT
WAS, UH WHAT THE INVESTIGATION
OR THE OUTCOME WAS. SO UM, OUR
INVESTIGATIONS EITHER CRIMINAL
OR ADMINISTRATIVE UM IF THEY ARE
SUBSTANTIATED, THEN GO TO EITHER
A PROSECUTING AGENCY OR FOR
INTERNAL DISCIPLINE, AND THOSE
AGENCIES THEN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
INVESTIGATION. EXCUSE ME WITH
THE INVESTIGATION THAT WE
CONDUCTED, UM, AND THERE ARE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WE DO NOT
SUBSTANTIATE. AND THEN THOSE GO
NÓ FURTHER. OK I DON'T THINK MY
QUESTIONS. MAYBE I'M NOT
EXPRESSING IT CORRECTLY. UM MORE
SO, FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND YOU
ASKING, PERHAPS MAYBE I CAN
CLARIFY. UM ARE YOU YOU'RE
ASKING WHETHER LIKE, FOR
INSTANCE, THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IS STATING THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE, UM IF THERE IS AN
ISSUE WITH THE OUTCOME OF THE
INVESTIGATION, INTEGRITY PROCESS
OF THE INVESTIGATION ARE IS
THERE SOME SORT OF, UM PROCESS
INTERNALLY THAT CAN BE DONE TO
PERHAPS CLARIFY WHAT HAPPENED
INTERNALLY OR EXTERNALLY, SO UM,
YOU KNOW, WITH EACH BODY WE HAVE
AN ESCALATOR, RIGHT? IF THERE
WAS SOMETHING WRONG HERE, WE CAN
APPEAL IT IN THE COURT SYSTEM.
WE CAN APPEAL IT TO THE NEXT
COURT. ABOVE IT WITH YOU. THE
RESULT OF YOUR, UM WITH YOUR THE
OUTCOMES OF YOUR INVESTIGATIONS.
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS AS TO
THE INTEGRITY OF THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS, AND THEY WOULD
LIKE TO BE AN APPEAL, PER S¼ E
IS THERE ANOTHER LEVEL OR
ANOTHER ENTITY IN WHICH UM,
PARTIES HAVE A RECOURSE TO GO TO
SO OUR OFFICE REPORTS TO THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. UM AND SO
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE BOARD
OF EDUCATION RELATED TO OUR WORK
. UM I AM PERSONALLY EVALUATED
BY THE BOARD OF EDUCATION, SO MY
WORK IS EVALUATED BY THEM. AND
IN ADDITION, EVERY THREE YEARS,
OUR OFFICE UNDERGOES A PEER
REVIEW TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
FOLLOWING THE PRINCIPLES AND
STANDARDS CORRECTLY. UM, AND
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN FOUND TO BE
FOLLOWING THOSE STANDARDS AND
PRINCIPLES. OK SO BASICALLY THE
RECOURSE WOULD BE THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. IF THERE WAS A
QUESTION AS TO THE INTEGRITY OF
THE INVESTIGATION. THERE IS
RECOURSE FOR PEOPLE LIKE IN THIS
CASE, THE CHARTER SCHOOLS PER S¼
E. IS THAT CORRECT? YES OK,
PERFECT. THANK YOU. AND I THINK
ANOTHER RECOURSE IS OUTSIDE
LITIGATION RIGHT. OTHER OTHER
RIGHT. THEY CAN INITIATE
INDEPENDENTLY LITIGATION
CORRECT, CORRECT SO THAT THAT
WOULD BE A BACK. CHECK ON THAT.
OK, UH, I'M BACK. SO, UM, ANY
ANY OTHER I MISSED PART OF IT,
BUT I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. BASED ON MY CONVERSATION
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
PORTION. WE HEARD MY
UNDERSTANDING, HAVING COME BACK
A LITTLE BIT LATE, SENATOR GELS.
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS? YES CORRECT
ACCEPTING THAT, AND I THINK WE
DID HAVE A MOTION SO MOTION FROM
SENATOR WE WITH THAT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? JUST WANNA THANK
OUR WITNESSES, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND OUR GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS TEAM AS WELL AS, UM AT
THE SENATORS WHO'VE ASKED THE
GOOD QUESTIONS ABOUT WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION, OF COURSE,
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
VOTE. THANK YOU, UH, WITH THAT,
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHILE ITEM SIX S¼ B
991 GONZALEZ MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN. I Ó I Ó I CORTESE
CORTESE EYE, GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ, I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
WILKY WILK. AY. UH, THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS FIVE VOTES. WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR SENATOR
SMALL CUEVAS. UH AND NEXT UP IS
S¼ P 1182. ALSO FROM THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM LONG BEACH, PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. UM I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT S¼ B 1182, WHICH WILL
REQUIRE CROSS AGENCY
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION
ON HOW CALIFORNIA CAN KEEP ITS
SCHOOLS SAFE IN AN ERA OF
EXTREME IMPACTS FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE. CALIFORNIA MAINTAINS
OVER 125,000 ACRES OF SCHOOL
GROUNDS. 730 MILLION SQUARE FEET
OF FACILITY. AND 10,000 SCHOOL
FACILITIES OF WHICH 40% OR AT
LEAST 50 YEARS OLD AND WE KNOW
FRONT LINE AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES BEAR
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF THE
CLIMATE IMPACTS. SB 1182 WILL
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE PLAN THAT
WILL BETTER POSITION
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
TACKLE THE GENERATIONAL
CHALLENGE OF TRANSITIONING TO
CLIMATE, RESILIENT SCHOOLS AND
FACILITIES AND TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. TODAY I HAVE MITCH
STEIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
DOCTOR, AMANDA MILSTEIN, A
PEDIATRICIAN AND CO-FOUNDER OF
CLIMATE HEALTH. NOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON SB 1182. VERY GOOD. M STEGER
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR
MEMBERS AND STAFF MITCH STEER
WITH èC F Tð, A UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL, ALONG WITH A
BROAD COALITION OF OTHER LIKE
MINDED GROUPS FOR A FEW
DIFFERENT REASONS, PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST, ONE OF WHICH IS THAT
OUR SCHOOLS ARE VERY OLD, AND
THEY ARE GETTING OLDER, AND MOST
OF THEM WERE BUILT IN AN ERA
WHEN WE WERE NOT THINKING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE. MY SON'S SCHOOL
WAS BUILT IN 1939 WHEN WE HAD A
LOT OF THINGS ON OUR MIND, BUT,
UH WE WEREN'T REALLY THINKING
ABOUT EXTREME HEAT AND WILDFIRE
AFFECTED AIR. AND OTHER CONCERNS
THAT ARE NOW TOP OF MIND WHEN WE
BUILD NEW EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND SO AS A
RESULT, WE'VE GOT A LONG WAY TO
GO TOWARDS MAKING SURE THAT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM IS READY FOR
WHAT'S HERE NOW AND WHAT'S
COMING. UM THE RESEARCH AT THIS
POINT IS PRETTY CLEAR THAT AS
HEAT RISES, THE ABILITY OF A
HUMAN BEING TO TEACH OR TO LEARN
THE CLIENTS AND IT'S THE SAME
WITH WILDFIRE AFFECTED AIR. WE
HAVE A LOT OF KIDS WITH ASTHMA.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TEACHERS WITH
ASTHMA, A LOT OF CLASSIFIED
WORKERS WITH DIFFERENT TYPES OF
TOY ILLNESSES THAT ARE VERY MUCH
WORSENED BY HARMFUL PARTICULATE
MATTER IN THE AIR, SO WE NEED TO
DO A LOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
READY JUST FOR THOSE TWO AS LONG
AS WELL AS A LOT OF OTHER
DIFFERENT IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AS THEY'RE COMING, AND SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS PUT US ON
A PATH TOWARDS BEING IN A MUCH
BETTER PLACE AND BEING MUCH MORE
READY TO DEAL WITH THOSE
IMPACTS. IT DOESN'T BUILD THINGS
ITSELF, BUT WHAT IT DOES DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THE MONEY
THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO SPEND AND
IT'S A LOT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SCHOOLS ARE MORE CLIMATE.
RESILIENT IS SPENT WISELY THAT
IT'S JUST WHOEVER'S ASKING THAT
WE HAVE A LONG LIST OF WHAT'S
MOST EFFECTIVE. WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT WHAT DO WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE SO THAT WE KNOW GOING
FORWARD? HOW DO WE GET THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK IN
TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT OUR
SCHOOLS ARE AS CLIMATE RESILIENT
AS THEY CAN POSSIBLY BE, SO IT'S
A HUGE ISSUE FOR US. IT'S A HUGE
ISSUE FOR OUR STUDENTS, AND WE
THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT STEP
FOR CALIFORNIA, SPEAKING MORE
BROADLY TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS, THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
THESE BUILDINGS OUT THERE, THEY
COULD DO A LOT BETTER IN TERMS
OF REDUCING OUR RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL FUELS. REDUCING JUST OUR
OVERALL ENERGY DEMANDS, AND THIS
BILL TAKES A HUGE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DR
MILLSTEIN. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY. MY NAME
IS DOCTOR. AMANDA MILSTEIN. I'M
A PEDIATRICIAN PRACTICING IN
OAKLAND, A CO-FOUNDER OF CLIMATE
HEALTH NOW AND PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THE MOTHER OF TWO
KIDS WHO ATTEND SCHOOL IN WEST
CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. UH, I AM ALSO HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ B 1182. I WANT TO
SHARE A STORY OF ONE OF MY
PATIENTS AND HIS GRANDPARENTS
WITH YOU ALL WHO I MET THIS PAST
SEPTEMBER IN MY URGENT CARE. IN
OAKLAND. MY PATIENT I'M GONNA
CALL HIM. CHARLIE TODAY WAS SICK
WITH A COLD. HE CAME IN WHEEZING
. HIS ASTHMA WAS BADLY FLARING
UP. THE AIR AROUND US WAS YET
AGAIN THICK WITH WILDFIRE SMOKE.
WHEN CAN HE GO BACK TO SCHOOL?
HIS GRANDPARENTS ASKED ME THE
WORRY CLEAR ON THEIR FACE. IT
GETS SMOKY IN MY CLASSROOM,
CHARLIE TOLD ME AS WE TALKED
THROUGH HOW GIVEN THE LACK OF
AIR FILTERS AND AIR CONDITIONING
IN HIS CLASSROOM. IT WAS NOT
SAFE FOR CHARLIE TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL, CLIMATE CHANGE, IMPACTS,
CHILD HEALTH AND LEARNING IN THE
CLASSROOM. IN MANY WAYS, HOT
DAYS RESULT IN POORER LEARNING
OUTCOMES, WITH BLACK AND
HISPANIC CHILDREN EXPERIENCING A
5% GAP IN STANDARDIZED TEST
SCORES COMPARED TO THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS DUE TO HEAT ALONE.
WILDFIRE SMOKE IS 10. TIMES AS
TOXIC AS THE REGULAR AIR
POLLUTION. WE BREATHE FROM
BURNING FOSSIL FUELS AND OUR
SCHOOLS ARE NOT EQUIPPED WITH
UPDATED OR EFFICIENT HVAC
SYSTEMS TO KEEP KIDS SAFE OR
HEALTHY. S¼ B 1182 WILL ENSURE
THAT THE $7 BILLION WE ALREADY
SPEND ON SCHOOL FACILITIES IN
EAST CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS, PART OF
OUR CLIMATE SOLUTIONS. IT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES MOST VULNERABLE TO
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE,
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO MAKE THE
UPGRADES TO KEEP THEIR STUDENTS
KIDS LIKE MY PATIENT, CHARLIE
SAFE, HEALTHY AND LEARNING.
THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH I CAN DO
IN MY CLINIC TO HELP OUR KIDS. I
NEED YOUR HELP, PLEASE, ON
BEHALF OF MY PATIENTS, MY KIDS,
ALL OF OUR KIDS IN CALIFORNIA
VOTE I ON S¼ B 118. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DOES ANYBODY ELSE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM LIKE
TEST ON BEHALF OF S¼? P 1182.
PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE. YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION. YOUR
POSITION. MR CHAIRS, MY QUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT. NAME
IS WEST SARAH WITH CHILDREN NOW
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN. CHAIR MEMBER, SAM
NASHER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DAVID BUN ON
BEHALF OF THE BUILDING.
DECARBONISATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MIKA
RANDOLPH WITH GREEN SCHOOLYARDS
AMERICA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HØI MEG SNYDER AXIOM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF REWIRING AMERICA IN
SUPPORT. PARTY. MY BS. WILL BEER
WITH CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
ORDERS IN SUPPORT. IS ANYBODY
HERE WITH US TODAY? I'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE. SEEING NONE. LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DA COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
SENATOR GONZALEZ OR THE
WITNESSES? NÓ èC BUG. SO I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE THE MEASURE WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE. UM I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT. BUT I DO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH REGARDS TO,
UM I GUESS TO THE BUDGET. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE ONLY CONCERN
THAT, UM, MAKES ME A LITTLE HAVE
WORRIED ABOUT WHERE WE GO FROM
HERE WITH WITH THE CHANCES IN
THE AND THE GOALS THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO, UM, ACHIEVE HERE WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL, UM, ALSO,
I JUST WANNA SAY FOR THE RECORD
THAT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
IT'S ALSO ADDING ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE èC èC.
IS THAT CORRECT? WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL SO THROUGH THE
CHAIR? YES WE, UM WE KNOW WE ARE
DEFERRING TO THE èC èC, BUT
WE'RE ALSO WE'VE CHANGED UP THE
BILL TO BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
WORK WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES
AS WELL. SO IT'S NOT SO èC
HEAVY. UM BUT, UM, I THINK TO
YOUR FORMER QUESTION ON THE
BUDGET. I MEAN, THE BIG QUESTION
. OF COURSE, IN THIS TIME OF
BUDGET DEFICIT, THE SPONSORS AND
I ARE LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
BUDGET SCENARIOS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR. UM, BILL, UM, WE
KNOW THAT, UH, WE WOULD BE
LEVERAGING AS BY DR MILSTEIN. A
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. UM, SO EVEN
IN THE ONE TIME COST, OF COURSE,
WE HAD AN ORIGINAL PRICE TAG OF
10 MILLION LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS WHERE WE CAN LESSEN
THAT COST. UM WHICH I LOOK AT IS
LIKE START UP CAPITAL TO BE ABLE
TO UNLOCK FEDERAL DOLLARS AT
BILLIONS WITH THE IRA A. THIS IS
A REALLY BIG OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
SO YES, WE'RE IN A SITUATION BUT
I THINK WE COULD BE, YOU KNOW,
HAVE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY DOWN
THE ROAD. OK, PERFECT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO FOR
MY PART. THIS IS A REDO WITH
SOME CHANGES TO S¼ B 394 FROM
LAST YEAR. UM I. I TOOK A LOOK.
AND I NOTED THAT IT THAT THAT
MEASURE GOT ALL OF ONE NÓ VOTE
ACROSS ALL OF ITS HEARINGS, SO
THAT THERE IS I'M ALWAYS
INTRIGUED THERE. THERE IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL BASIS FOR
OVERRIDING OF VETO, WHICH WE
NEVER, UH WE HAVEN'T DONE SINCE
1978. BUT THIS THIS MIGHT BE A
GOOD CASE STUDY. UH, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT? WHAT IS? WHAT IS
YOUR, UH UH, SORT OF GUIDANCE
HERE CONSIDERING THAT SENATOR IS
BOGUE. YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
BUDGET. COMPONENT TO THIS, BUT
THIS IS SOME CHANGES BUT
FUNCTIONALLY SIMILAR TO A BILL
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN VETO. SO HOW
SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT THAT?
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY VALID QUESTION.
AND YOU KNOW, UM, DON'T TOUCH ME
WITH A GOOD TIME ON THE VETO OF
IT. LETS DO IT. I, UM I THINK
THIS IS, YOU KNOW, OF COURSE.
VERY RIGHTEOUS BILL. I MEAN,
YOU'VE GOT ALL OF THE INCREDIBLE
SPONSORS THAT HAVE COME TOGETHER
IN LABOR AND IN, UM, INDUSTRY,
BUT IN ALSO IN, UH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL, UM, ASPECT AND
MOMS, YOU KNOW, MANY OF US ARE
MOMS OF CHILDREN. IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW, THAT REALLY
SEE THE NEED. WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT FACILITIES ARE
AGING, SO WE'LL CONTINUE ON THAT
MESSAGE. BUT I THINK AGAIN,
WE'RE REVISING THE BUDGET TO
LOOK AT WHAT WE CAN DO TO LESSEN
THE START UP CAPITAL IF YOU WILL
TO BE ABLE TO UNLOCK THOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS THROUGH THE IRA
AND IIJ A. SO FOR AN EXAMPLE
I'LL GIVE YOU THEM IF, UH, IF
YOU WANNA PURCHASE AND INSTALL A
500 KILOWATT SOLAR SYSTEM AT A
COST OF A MILLION DOLLARS, IT
COULD RECEIVE A DIRECT PAYMENT
OF BETWEEN THREE 100 TO 500 Kò
BACK FROM THE IRA. SO THE RETURN
, I THINK IS PRETTY, UM,
SIGNIFICANT. UM, AND THEN TO BE
ABLE TO ADD, UM YOU KNOW, OF
COURSE, GOOD JOBS, SO THAT WOULD
BE FANTASTIC AND WILD, WILD
DECARBONIZING ON TOP OF THAT, SO
I THINK THE RETURN IS DRASTIC. I
APPRECIATE THAT. CAN WE TAKE
THAT AS AS YOUR CLOSE?
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. SO I WOULD
I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL. I
KNOW. WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
SENATOR CIO BOGA I. I URGE YOU
TO SPEAK TO THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER ABOUT THIS WHOLE VETO
OVER, I THINK BUT WITH THAT
WE'VE GOT A MOTION AND LET US
CALL THE RULE. WHILE ITEM SEVEN
S¼ B 1182 GONZALEZ MOTION IS DUE
PAST TO IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN, I Ó I
Ó I, CORTES CORTES, I GLAZER
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ, I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WILK. AYE, WILK. AYE.
EXCELLENT UH, LET'S SEE. WE HAVE
TWO MEASURES LEFT. NEXT IS SB
1411 FROM OUR COLLEAGUE, SENATOR
CIOBO. I YES. YES.
WELL, SHE'S COMING UP. CAN WE
ONCE AGAIN VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? JUST SO THOROUGH
SOMEDAY YOU SHOULD SHARE SHARE
THIS COMMITTEE. UH IF YOU DON'T
MIND, SENATOR SHOW BUG, SENATOR
WILK IS CLEARLY HAS SOMEWHERE TO
GO. NOT AT ALL. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
NOT DOING IT. OK, AWESOME AT AT.
UH, PLEASE PROCEED. UH AND, UH,
YOU ARE PRESENTING SB 1411. YES.
THANK YOU. AND GOOD MORNING,
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DURING THE
LAST REVISION OF CALIFORNIA'S
MATH CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK 2020
THREE 2020 TO 2020, THREE, MANY
PROFESSORS AND EXPERTS IN
QUANTITATIVE FIELDS EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT THE FRAMEWORKS GUIDANCE
WOULD HAVE ON STUDENTS ENTERING
COLLEGE AND THE WORKFORCE AND
HOW THE FRAMEWORK WOULD HARM THE
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS IT WAS
SEEKING TO HELP. A RECENT REPORT
RELEASED BY THE UC'S BOARD OF
ADMISSIONS AND RELATIONS WITH
SCHOOLS BOARDS AREA èC WORK
GROUP FOUND THAT SPECIFIC
COURSES EMPHASIZED BY THE NEW
MATHEMATICS FRAMEWORK DO NOT
EVEN COME CLOSE TO MEETING THE
REQUIRED STANDARDS TO BE A MORE
ADVANCED COURSE THEY DETERMINE
THESE COURSES WOULD NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE MATH COURSES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADMISSIONS BEGINNING
IN 2025 TO 2026 AS A RESULT,
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WHO
CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN COURSES
APPROVED BY THE NEW MATHEMATICS
FRAMEWORK WILL NÓ LONGER BE
ALLOWED TO COUNT THEM TOWARDS
ADMISSIONS TO COLLEGE. S¼ B 1411
WOULD TEST THE INTERSEGMENT
COMMITTEE OF ACADEMIC SENATES. A
0.6 COLLEGE FACULTY SUBJECT
MATTER. EXPERTS TO SERVE AS
MEMBERS ON THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION IQ èC. I
SEE. I SEE AS GOAL IS TO IMPROVE
STUDENT ACCESS AND SUCCESS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION BY PROVIDING
ADVICE TO Kò 12 EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERS AND THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF PREPARATION FOR
STUDENTS ENTERING A COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY IQ èC HAS EIGHT
SUBJECT MATTER COMMITTEES THAT
ADOPT CURRICULUM BASED ON
SUBJECT AREA SUCH AS ARTS,
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS, ENGLISH
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT. HISTORY
SOCIAL SCIENCE, MATHEMATICS,
PHYSICAL EDUCATION, SCIENCE AND
WORLD LANGUAGES. HOWEVER MANY OF
THESE COMMITTEES ONLY HAVE ONE
SUBJECT MATTER. EXPERT
OVERSEEING THE ADVICE PERTAINING
TO THAT ACADEMIC DISCIPLINE.
UNDER S¼ B 1411. I èC. WOULD
APPOINT TWO SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS FROM EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM TO PARTICIPATE
IN DISCUSSIONS AROUND CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT AND MATERIALS ADOPT
ADOPTION. THESE HIGHER EDUCATION
PROFESSIONALS WILL IMPROVE
COMMITTEE DIVERSITY AND PROVIDE
INSIGHT TO MEMBERS REGARDING Kò
12 CURRICULUM AND COURSE CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE NECESSARY
FOR STUDENTS PREPARING TO ENTER
HIGHER EDUCATION. JOINING ME IN
SUPPORT IS PROFESSOR BRIAN
CONRAD FROM STANFORD UNIVERSITY,
UH, AS WELL AS PROFESSOR JELANI
NELSON FROM U èC BERKELEY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
AND SO THE WITNESSES ARE HERE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS OR TO
PRESENT YOU HAVE YOUR OWN, BUT
YOU HAVE TESTIMONIES AS WELL. IS
PRESENTING HER TESTIMONY. TWO
MINUTES EACH, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JELANI
NELSON AND I'M A PROFESSOR IN
UPCOMING DIVISION CHAIR OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE AT U èC,
BERKELEY. TODAY. I'M HERE TO
CONVEY MY OWN THOUGHTS AND I AM
NOT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPUS OR THE KEYWORD OF MY
TESTIMONY TODAY ON S¼ B 1411 IS
ALIGNMENT. S¼ P 1411 ESTABLISHES
A STRONGER FOUNDATION OF
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN Kò 12
EDUCATORS AND THOSE IN FACULTY
GOVERNANCE AND PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CURRICULAR FRAMEWORK GUIDANCE IN
HIGH SCHOOL, HELPING ALIGN THE
EDUCATION STUDENTS NEED TO HELP
THEM SUCCEED IN COLLEGE. BY
APPOINTING REPRESENTATIVES FROM
OUR THREE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS TO THE IQ èC.
THEY WILL HELP DEVELOP FUTURE
CURRICULAR FROM A HANDFUL OF
HIGHER ED CONSULTANTS, AS IS THE
PRACTICE TODAY. SB 1411 SETS UP
A PROCESS THAT ALSO INCLUDES A
HIGH BANDWIDTH CONNECTION TO THE
BODY OF HIGHER ED FACULTY. VR
FORMAL FACULTY GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES THAT THESE NEW IQ èC
MEMBERS REPRESENT. WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
IS NOT ONLY THE EXPERTISE OF A
SMALL SET OF INDIVIDUALS FROM
HIGHER ED, BUT ADDITIONALLY THAT
HIGH BANDWIDTH CONNECTION TO
THOSE EXISTING STRUCTURES THESE
FACULTY GOVERNMENT STRUCTURES
ARE RELEVANT FOR TWO REASONS.
FIRST THERE ARE COMMITTEES THINK
VERY HARD ABOUT THE PREPARATION
STUDENTS NEED FOR POST-SECONDARY
SUCCESS. FOR EXAMPLE, I èC UM,
HAS PUBLISHED GUIDANCE ON
COMPETENCIES STUDENTS SHOULD
ACQUIRE IN HIGH SCHOOL
INSTRUCTION A WIDE RANGE OF
AREAS AS THE VICE CHAIR
MENTIONED. AND SECOND, IT IS
THESE STRUCTURES THAT DETERMINE
EMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS, SUBJECT
TO OVERSIGHT BY THE U èC BOARD
OF REGENTS AND THUS HAVING THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE ROOM
IMPROVES ALIGNMENT. FOR THESE
REASONS, I, I URGE YOUR I VOTE
ON S¼ B 1411. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OK UH, GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. UH, MY NAME IS BRIAN
CONRAD AND I'M, A MATH PROFESSOR
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY. I'VE
ALSO BEEN THE DIRECTOR OF
UNDERGRADUATE STUDIES IN MATH AT
STANFORD FOR THE PAST 10 YEARS.
IN THAT ROLE. I'VE SPOKEN WITH
MANY FACULTY AT U, S¼, CAL STATE
AND COLLEGES AND OTHER STATES
ABOUT QUANTITATIVE SKILLS
RELEVANT TO CONTEMPORARY COLLEGE
DEGREES AND JOBS. SENATE BILL
1411 STRENGTHENS THE ALIGNMENT
OF CURRICULAR FRAMEWORKS WITH
THE SKILLS NEEDED FOR THE FUTURE
WORKFORCE EXPERIENCED Kò 12
TEACHERS IN DISTRICT STAFF CAN
JUDGE BOTH GRADE LEVEL
APPROPRIATENESS AND THE BRIDGE
FROM ELEMENTARY TO MIDDLE TO
HIGH SCHOOLS. BUT COLLEGE
FACULTY PREPARES STUDENTS IN
CRITICAL WAYS FOR JOBS OF THE
FUTURE. REPRESENTATION ON THE IQ
èC FROM ALL THREE PILLARS OF
PUBLIC, HIGHER EDUCATION,
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, CAL STATE
AND THE U èC SYSTEM WILL
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE RANGE OF
PERSPECTIVES FOR ENSURING
COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS. JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY, IT WILL ENHANCE THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE
REQUIRED FOR ASSESSING
CURRICULAR FRAMEWORKS. IN A
RECENT JOINT STATEMENT FROM THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF TEACHERS OF
MATHEMATICS AND THE MATHEMATICAL
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA, THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CONTINUUM OF
EXPERTISE FROM Kò 12 TEACHERS TO
COLLEGE FACULTY WHO IS
EMPHASIZED IN THE FOLLOWING TWO
WAYS THAT APPLY EQUALLY WELL TO
ALL DISCIPLINES, BRINGING HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHERS AND COLLEGE
FACULTY TOGETHER TO COORDINATE
AND IMPLEMENT INSTRUCTIONAL AND
CURRICULAR PRACTICES SUPPORT
STUDENTS IN THEIR TRANSITION
FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE.
SECOND INVOLVING HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHERS AND COLLEGE FACULTY IN
EFFORTS TO CREATE NEW CURRICULA
PROVIDES FOR A VARIETY OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS. IN
THIS WAY. THE PROPOSED EXPANSION
OF THE IQ èC WILL ENABLE IT TO
BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. AND SO I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL
1411. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
PROFESSOR. IS ANYBODY ELSE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. NAME ORGANIZATION. YOUR
POSITION. MARK EPSTEIN,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK.
UM, NOT ALL THAT FAMILIAR WITH
THE BILL. BUT ONE THING I WANT
TO POINT OUT IS WE HAVE HAD AN
EVOLUTION IN OUR WORKFORCE. ONE
THING THAT IS BECOMING APPARENT
IS THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
BEGINNING TO DEVELOP A
DEFICIENCY OF UNDERSTANDING AND
UTILIZING DATA AND
INTERPRETATION OF DATA AS OUR
WORKFORCE IS CHANGING AND WITHIN
OUR MATH CURRICULUM AND BEYOND
JUST MATH CONTENT, BUT ACROSS
CONTENT. WE NEED A MORE EMPHASIS
OF WHERE STUDENTS ARE WORKING
WITH AND INTERPRETING DATA.
THANK YOU, MR EPSTEIN. NEXT
WEEK. GOOD AFTERNOON. UH,
DOCTOR, CHRISTINE ISAACSON. IN
SUPPORT, AND I'M WITH THE
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
1411. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
DOCTOR. IS ANYBODY HERE WHO'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL? I KNOW WE HAVE TRUST
WEST WELCOME. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. WE'VE SAVED YOU A SEAT.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. I'M BRIAN RES,
REPRESENTING THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST, AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE IN WERE OPPOSED BECAUSE
WE LOOKED AT THE BILL. WE LOOKED
AT THE PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT THE
SENATOR HAS INTRODUCED AND WE
LOOK AT LOOKED AT THE AUTHOR'S
FACT SHEET AND WE CONCLUDED THAT
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO REALLY
RELITIGATE OR UNDO THE 2023 MATH
FRAMEWORK. IT'S ASKING YOU TO GO
BACK AND ALTER THE COMPOSITION
OF AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT
APPROVED A FRAMEWORK THAT, UH,
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL DISAGREED
WITH. WE THINK THAT'S BAD
POLICY. UM AND I THINK AS
EVIDENCE OF WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THIS BILL, LOOK AT ONE OF THE
OTHER BILLS THAT SPEAKS DIRECTLY
TO EIGHTH GRADE ALGEBRA. THAT
WAS ONE OF THE FLASHPOINTS IN
ONE OF THE MAJOR CONTROVERSIES
IN THE 2020 THREE FRAMEWORK, AND
ONE OF THE OTHER BILLS THAT IS
BEING BROUGHT FORWARD WOULD
WOULD SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THAT
POINT. WE THINK IT'S BAD POLICY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO GO BACK
AND ALTER THE COMPOSITION OF
ADVISORY COMMITTEES. WHEN ONE
SIDE DISAGREED WITH THE DECISION
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY MADE, WE
THINK YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING AT.
WAS IT AN OPEN PROCESS? WAS IT A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS? WAS IT WAS
IT INCLUSIVE? EMPHATICALLY THE
ANSWER TO THOSE QUESTIONS ARE
YES. YES AND, YES, THE 2020
THREE FRAMEWORK WAS OUT FOR
MULTIPLE PUBLIC PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIODS OVER SEVERAL YEARS. WE
WEIGHED IN WITH OUR VIEWS WE
INVITE. WE WOULD SAY OTHERS
SHOULD BE INVITED TO DO THE SAME
. AND FRANKLY, WHEN WE DISAGREE
WITH A DECISION IN EDUCATION
POLICY, WE DON'T COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAY CHANGE THE
MAKEUP OF THE GROUP THAT MADE IT
. WE WEIGH IN WITH OUR ARGUMENTS
, OUR FACTS AND OUR ADVOCACY. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS, RESPECTFULLY,
WE'RE OPPOSED. THAT IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE HERE, AS OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE? SEE ACTUALLY, MS
RIVAS, YOU MIGHT WANT TO STAY.
UM SO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES, SENATOR GONZALEZ. UH
ACKNOWLEDGING THE OPPOSITION IN
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT'S I WOULD
BE HAPPY UP THROUGH THE CHAIR.
YOU'LL BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS IT.
THAT'S FINE, PLEASE. SO GRATEFUL
THAT HE BROUGHT THAT POINT THAT
ARE MR RIVAS HAS BROUGHT THAT
POINT FORWARD. UM YES, OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE CURRICULUM AS
I STAND IS, BUT I THINK IT'S NOT
BECAUSE OF THE CURRICULUM, THE
MATH CURRICULUM THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE SYSTEM, BUT IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE MATH CURRICULUM
THAT WAS APPROVED PRIMARILY
DURING THIS THE DURING THE
STAGES OF COVID, BY THE WAY, UM,
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THIS HAS
ALLOWED US TO COME BACK AND LOOK
AT THE SYSTEM THAT MADE THIS
POSSIBLE TO INS TO ANALYZE AS
THIS SYSTEM OR SYSTEMICALLY
WHERE WE HAVE GAPS. WHY WE HAVE
DEFICIENCIES IN INPUT AND
FEEDBACK. WHEN IT COMES TO
CURRICULUM. THIS IS WHY THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED AND THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED, BUT MANY STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE STATE THIS BILL IS
COMING FORWARD BECAUSE WE'RE
REALIZING THAT IN IN THE PROCESS
OF HAVING THE SYSTEM THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE PLACED THAT'S
ADDRESSING CURRICULUM FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
EDUCATIONAL GAPS OF EXPERTISE
COMING TO THE TABLE, GIVING THAT
FEEDBACK HENCE THE PROFESSOR IS
HERE TODAY FROM UH FROM STANFORD
AND BERKELEY, EXPRESSING THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SYSTEM AND
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. UM
AND JUST TO BE FAIR IT IT'S IS
MR REEVES, ALSO PART OF THE
GROUPS THAT WERE PART OF THE
SYSTEM THAT MADE THE CURRICULUM
POSSIBLE. SO, UM YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A BIAS
IN THERE AS WELL. IT WOULD BE
THIS INGENUOUS FOR HIM TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL BECAUSE
HE IS PART OF THE SYSTEM THAT
MADE THIS POSSIBLE. SO UM, JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT ALSO CLEAR,
TRANSPARENT. ALL RIGHT, WELL,
LET LET ME I'M LOOKING FOR
CHRISTINE ISAACSON. I THINK
SHE'S SHE'S STILL HERE. SHE LIVE
? I GUESS THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
UH, LET LET ME ASK YOU,
PROFESSOR  N. I MEAN, SO YOU
KNOW, I. I THINK YOUR POINT IS,
I APPRECIATE IT HERE, BUT I
GUESS MY QUESTION WOULD BE WOULD
ALL TRAINING ADVISORY COMMITTEE,
UH, IN YOUR VIEW, NECESSARILY
LEAD TO A CHANGE IN THAT POLICY
OR THE RECENT POLICY DECISIONS
BY THE RQ. THE RECENT YOU MEAN
THE RECENT CALIFORNIA MATH
FRAMEWORK? YES. I MEAN, IF THE
ASSERTION HERE IS THAT THIS IS
INSTIGATED IN RESPONSE TO A
POLICY MEASURE RIGHT WITH A WITH
A DIRECT INTEREST IN REVERSING
THAT, YOU KNOW, BY CHANGING THE
COMPOSITION, YOU KNOW IF WE WERE
TO ADD PER THE BILL, YOU KNOW
THE SIX MEMBERS 22 AND TWO DO
YOU THINK THAT WOULD HAVE HAD AN
IMPACT, YOU KNOW, AND WILL THAT
LEAD NECESSARILY TO A REVISITING
OF THIS POLICY? SO UM, RALPH,
I'LL I'LL AVOID STATING SOME
OPINIONS, AND I'LL I'LL JUST
PRESENT SOME FACTS THAT I THINK,
YOU KNOW, MAKE MAKE THE CASE
THAT I WANNA MAKE, UM, YOU KNOW.
THE REASON THAT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
RELITIGATING THE PAST. UM I'M
LOOKING AT IT FOR THE FUTURE. UM
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU BUT
IF YOU DO LOOK AT THE PAST UM
YOU KNOW, IN IN CHAPTER EIGHT OF
THE CALIFORNIA MATH WAY
FRAMEWORK THERE WERE THERE WERE
CERTAIN PATHWAYS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
MATHEMATICS. THREE YEAR
SEQUENCES FOR FRESHMAN SOPHOMORE
JUNIOR YEAR THAT WERE THAT WERE
ADVOCATED. AND YOU KNOW, KIND OF
WHILE THE LATEST REVERSION WAS
BEING DEVELOPED. WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN PARALLEL IN TIME
WAS RESOLUTIONS WERE BEING PUT
FORWARD IN THE CAL STATE SYSTEM,
YOU KNOW, IN THE U èC SYSTEM
THAT WERE SAYING, OH, THESE,
THESE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWABLE
LIKE THESE PATHWAYS HAVE
PROBLEMS. UM REGARDING THE AREA
èC REQUIREMENTS, THE ADMISSION
REQUIREMENTS AND THOSE PEOPLE
WEREN'T IN THE ROOM. YOU KNOW,
UH, AS THE FRAMEWORK WAS BEING
DEVELOPED, SO THEY WEREN'T HEARD
THIS LED TO A LAST MINUTE
ADDENDUM. UH, BEING INTRODUCED
INTO THE MATH FRAMEWORK THE
MORNING OF THE VOTE ON JULY 12TH
LAST YEAR, RIGHT? AND IF THOSE
PEOPLE HAD BEEN IN THE ROOM FROM
THE BEGINNING, I THINK IT WOULD
HAVE JUST IT WOULD JUST HELPED.
IT WOULD HAVE JUST HELPED
ALIGNMENT. I MEAN, THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY WHAT I'M HERE ABOUT IS
FOR THE FUTURE. HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT RELEVANT PARTIES ARE
ALIGNED. OK, UM II, I WILL SAY
FOR MY PART I MEAN, WE HAVEN'T
HAD MATH FOLKS HERE TODAY. BUT
I, I THINK IT'S A BROADER
CONTEXT. UH, WE AS A LEGISLATURE
HAVE DELEGATED SUBSTANTIAL
AUTHORITY TO THE INSTRUCTION OF
QUALITY COMMISSION. AND IN FACT,
WE HAVE A POLICY THAT
DELIBERATELY DEFERS TO THE IQ
èC WHEN IT COMES TO
LEGISLATION, EXCEPT IN KIND OF
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES, SO
I SO I THINK I'M GENERALLY UH
UH, SORT OF PERSUADABLE THAT
MORE AND BETTER PARTICIPATION IS
A GOOD THING, ESPECIALLY BY
MEMBERS OF DIFFERENT SEGMENTS
THAT HAVE NOT ONLY A DIRECT
VESTED INTEREST, BUT ALSO
SIGNIFICANT EXPERTISE. UM YOU
KNOW, SO I WAS JUST REAL QUICKLY
. YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR RESPONSE,
UH TO THAT? UH, DEFINITELY SEE
THE NEED FOR ALIGNMENT. MR
CHAIRMAN. I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON. WITH THIS BILL.
THERE WAS AMPLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
HIGHER ED FACULTY TO BE INVOLVED
AND GIVE INPUT. IN FACT, THE
AUTHORS OF THE 2023 FRAMEWORK
WERE FROM HIGHER EDUCATION. AND
THAT KIND OF ILLUSTRATES FROM
THE POINT OF VIEW OF PROPONENTS.
THOSE WERE THE WRONG HIGHER ED
PERSPECTIVES. THIS IS ABOUT
PERSPECTIVE SHOPPING. OK YOU
KNOW, THAT MAY BE THE IMPETUS,
BUT I THINK THE BROADER
FRAMEWORK IS ACTUALLY PRETTY
COMPELLING TO ME. BUT YOU KNOW,
I APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
THERE. SO, UH, DID WE HAVE A
MOTION? SENATOR WILKS AND
SENATOR CHIBO. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? CURLY. THANK YOU. IN
CLOSING, SB 14 AND 11 WOULD
ALLOW HIGHER EDUCATION EXPERTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT. ALL CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENTS, BY THE WAY, NOT
JUST MATH, BUT ALL CURRICULUMS.
UM DEVELOPMENT DISCUSSIONS AND
PROVIDE INSIGHT AND IMPROVE Kò
12 COURSE CONTENT, SO STUDENTS
HAVE A CLEAR PATHWAY TO COLLEGE.
UM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR WILK, MANU
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM EIGHT S¼ VÆ 1411 OBO.
MOTION IS DUE PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN, I, OCHO, I OCH I CORTES
CORTES, I GLASER GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ, I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WILKE WILKE.
ALL RIGHT NOW THAT MEASURE IS
ACTUALLY OUT 64 TO 0, AND WE
HAVE ONE LAST MEASURE WHICH IS
MINE. I WILL HAND THE GAVEL. TO
SENATOR CIOBO. UH,
WELCOME, SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU. UH, SO, MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB 1244, WHICH WILL
EXPAND DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS BY
ENHANCING THE ABILITY OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ENTER INTO COLLEGE
AND CAREER ACCESS PATHWAY
PROGRAMS WITH OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN WHICH A
SCHOOL IS LOCATED, IS EITHER
UNABLE OR UNWILLING TO ENTER
INTO SUCH AN AGREEMENT. FIRST
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME BACKGROUND
AND CONTEXT. UH, DO DUAL AND
ROLL PROGRAMS ALLOW HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT TO TAKE COLLEGE COURSES
AND EARN COLLEGE CREDITS WHILE
STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL. THESE
PROGRAMS, ALSO KNOWN AS COLLEGE
AND CAREER ACCESS, PATHWAY, OR
èC, èC, A P PROGRAMS WERE
DESIGNED TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
COLLEGE LEVEL LEARNING, UH, AND
TO HELP STUDENTS ACCELERATE THE
TIME IT TAKES TO COMPLETE
COLLEGE UPON GRADUATION FROM
HIGH SCHOOL, UH, GIVING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSES HELPS THEM
SIMULTANEOUSLY PREPARE FOR THE
ACADEMIC RIGORS OF COLLEGE WHILE
ALSO GIVING THEM A HEAD START ON
OBTAINING COLLEGE CREDITS. DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
FOUND TO HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT.
AND AN STUDENT'S GRADUATION
RATES, BUT THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
ACADEMICS AND COLLEGE COMPLETION
RATES AS WELL. S¼ B 1244 WOULD
AUTHORIZE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TO ENTER INTO A èC èC
A PARTNERSHIP AND PROVIDE ACCESS
TO DUAL ENROLLMENT COURSES TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITHIN THE
SERVICE AREA OF ANOTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
IN WHICH THAT SCHOOL IS LOCATED,
HAS EITHER DECLINED A SIMILAR
REQUEST OR HAS FAILED TO TAKE
ACTION WITHIN 60 DAYS OF A
REQUEST TO ENTER INTO
PARTNERSHIP FOR DUAL ENROLLMENT
COURSE. UNDER CURRENT STATUTE,
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM ENTERING INTO
èC èC, A P PARTNERSHIPS WITH
ANY SCHOOL, LOCATED IN ANOTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE'S SERVICE AREA
UNLESS THERE IS AN EXISTING
AGREEMENT IN PLACE BETWEEN THE
TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS,
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE A LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT FAILS
TO TAKE ACTION ON A REQUEST OR
DENIES IT FOR WHATEVER REASON,
BUT WHERE THAT DISTRICT HAS NÓ
AGREEMENT CURRENTLY IN PLACE
WITH ANOTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
TYPICALLY A NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT HAS
RESULTED IN SITUATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE, WHERE HIGH SCHOOL
SEEKING DUAL ENROLLMENT
PARTNERSHIPS HAVE BEEN PREVENTED
FROM DOING SO TO THE DETRIMENT
OF THEIR STUDENTS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE REAPED THE PROVEN
BENEFITS OF SUCH A PROGRAM. S¼
1244 WILL ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
ARE NOT DENIED QUALITY DUAL
ENROLLMENT OPPORTUNITIES DUE TO
PROVISIONS IN CURRENT LAW, WHICH
EFFECTIVELY AFFORD LOCAL
COMMUNITY. COLLEGE DISTRICTS
VETO POWER OVER AN AREA SCHOOL
DISABILITY TO FIND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEIR STUDENTS TO ACCESS
THIS VERY VALUABLE EDUCATIONAL
MODEL HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1244 IS PETER BIRDSALL,
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
COALITION. AND SARAH BASH IS
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION POLICY AND
ADVOCATE FOR THE NONPROFIT
CHILDREN NOW I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR I VOTE TODAY. I
WANT TO WELCOME THE LEAD
WITNESSES, PLEASE. STATE YOUR
NAME, UH, ONE MORE TIME. AND UH,
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. PETER
BIRDSALL, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL COALITION
COALITION, CONSISTS OF ABOUT 55
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT CAME TOGETHER TO
FOCUS ON ISSUES THAT IMPACT HIGH
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
. UM, WE'RE VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF EXPANDING, UH,
DUAL ENROLLMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. UM THE
SITUATION THE SENATOR NEWMAN
DESCRIBED IS EXACTLY THE
SITUATION FACED BY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE. I
HAVE A NUMBER OF EXAMPLES WHERE
A NEIGHBOR WHAT I'LL CALL A
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IS PREPARED TO ENTER
INTO A DUAL ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT
. UM BUT THEY CAN'T DO IT
BECAUSE THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE JUST DOESN'T RESPOND.
THEY DON'T SAY NÓ. THEY DON'T
REACH AGREEMENT. THEY JUST THE
CLOCK KEEPS TICKING. UM SO WITH
THIS CHANGE, WE THINK THERE WILL
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE. UM
COLLEGE CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS
FOR STUDENTS IN ACCORDANCE WITH
ALL THE PROVISIONS OF LAW THAT
BE FULLY COMPLIANT. THEY'RE JUST
WITH THE NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THAT'S UH, PREPARED TO
ENTER INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT. SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, SARA
B¢O WITH CHILDREN. NOW WE'RE
ALSO PLEASED TO BE A COSPONSOR.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS,
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN ADDRESSING ALL OF
THE BARRIERS TO ACCESS HIGHER
EDUCATION BY IMPROVING HIGH
SCHOOL TO COLLEGE TRANSITIONS
FOR MORE STUDENTS, PARTICULARLY
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND THOSE FROM
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND SO
WE KNOW THAT TAKING COLLEGE
COURSES EARLIER THROUGH THESE
INITIATIVES SUCH AS DUAL
ENROLLMENT HELP HOWEVER, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS REC,
UH, HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES.
WE SHOULDN'T JUST ALLOW. UM
INABILITIES TO ACCESS. UM
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT COMMUNICATING
AT THE YOU KNOW, BUREAUCRATIC
LEVEL BE THE HINDRANCE FOR OUR
CHILDREN. SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT, AND WE
REQUEST YOUR EYES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE WANT TO THANK BOTH
OF OUR LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1244. WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ B 1244. GOOD
MORNING. MARK EPSTEIN,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK,
AND WANNA COMMEND THE SENATOR ON
TAKING ON A BILL WITH THIS ISSUE
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
THE SERVICE AREA PROBLEM, WHICH
HAS BEEN, UM DETRIMENTAL FOR èC
Tð E EDUCATION, HOWEVER, OF
GOING BEYOND THE TOOL
ENROLLMENT, WE JUST NAME AND, UM
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORTER IN
SUPPORT. HØI I'M SORRY. NOT TOO
BAD. TO THE S¼ P. WE BE HAPPY
TO, UH, IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
WRITE A LETTER WITH YOUR, UH,
SUPPORT POSITIONS WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONSIDER THAT. AS
A COMMITTEE. UH, GOOD MORNING.
RON. ROBERT MURE, CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, VALERIE JOHNSON WITH
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, DOMINIQUE DE
AT VOICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, JAY VU ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CAL SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MORNING SABRINA MEANS
ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION. THE
ASSOCIATION IS MEETING NEXT WEEK
TO TAKE FORMAL POSITIONS ON
BILLS, BUT WE'RE RECOMMENDING A
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? YOU'RE IN ROOM 2100
èC  N  N WILL NOW GO ON TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO S¼ P
1244. NÓ LEAD WITH OPPOSITION.
SO ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO S¼ B 1244. THE  N
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS? SENATOR
GONZALEZ. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ TO MOVE THE
BILL. MADAM SECRETARY. OH I'M
SORRY. YES AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
I APOLOGIZE. SO THANK YOU TO MY
WITS, ESPECIALLY FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AND YOU KNOW, GETTING
TO THE END OF THIS HEARING. UH
THE YOU KNOW, THEY'RE DUAL
ENROLLMENT IS A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM IT IT. IT PROVIDES NOT
ONLY KIND OF THE OBVIOUS
BENEFITS, BUT IT ALSO GIVES
STUDENTS YOUNG PEOPLE THE
ABILITY TO EXPERIENCE COLLEGE
AND REALIZE THAT THEY CAN ASPIRE
TO THAT NEXT STEP IN THEIR
EDUCATION. THERE'S ACTUALLY NÓ
VILLAIN IN THIS BILL. UH, THIS
THE ORIGINAL CONCEPT DID NOT
ANTICIPATE THE CHALLENGES THAT,
UH, SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE FACED.
SO THIS SIMPLY YOU KNOW, SORT OF
MEETS THAT UNANTICIPATED, UH,
CIRCUMSTANCE AND WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT LATITUDES SO THAT
MORE STUDENTS CAN BENEFIT FROM
DO ENROLLMENT. I ASK FOR YOUR
IVO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM. 10 S¼ B 1244 NEWMAN
MOTION IS DUE PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN, I Ó I Ó I, CORTESE
CORTESE I BLAZER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ, I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS,
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS IY WILK WILK.
OK THIS BILL IS OUT. 620.
CONGRATULATIONS, SENATOR NEWMAN.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME OPEN
VOTES. SO MADAM CONSULTANT IF
YOU COULD CALL THE OPEN VOTES,
PLEASE. OK? ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ, IY
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, SMALL WOOD
CUEVAS I, THE CONSENT COUNTER IS
AT SIX VOTES TO ZERO. UH FILE
ITEM ONE S¼ B 1091 MEN OF OUR
MOTION IS DUE PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR EYES NÓ NOS
WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING I GLASER GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS,
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I THAT MEASURES
OUT SIX VOTES TO ZERO ITEM THREE
S¼ B. SB 1248 HURTADO MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR AYS AND NÓ NOS. WHAT THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I.
GLASER GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I
SMALL WITH CUEVAS, SMALL WOOD
QUES. I MEASURED AT SIX VOTES TO
ZERO FILE ITEM. FOUR S¼ B 1318
WAHAB MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE AYS AND NÓ
NOSE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING. I
PATROL B¢O LASER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS,
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I AND THEN
MEASURE THAT FIVE VOTES TO ZERO.
ITEM FIVE S¼ B 1491 EGG MAN
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. CURRENT
VOTE IS TWO IS A AND TWO NOS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I GLASER
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. I AND
MEASURE US OUT FOUR VOTES TO
TWO. UH, FILE ITEM SIX. S¼ 991
GONZALEZ MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
AYS AND NÓ NOS WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING. I GLASER
SMALLWOOD CUVA SMALL WITH CUVA
IY. THAT MEASURES THAT SIX VOTES
TO ZERO FILE ITEM. SEVEN S¼ P
1182 GONZALEZ MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
AYS AND NÓ NOSE WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR. VOTING I BLAZER.
MÀ CUEVAS, SMALL CUEVAS. I AND
THAT MEASURES THAT 6 FT TO ZERO
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT FINISHES
THE ROLE. UH, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO STAFF. THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES. WITH THAT THE SENATE
COMMUNITY EDUCATION IS
OFFICIALLY ADJOURNED.